[Music]
hmm
hey guys what's up
i'm live right now on youtube with you
guys i'm just gonna wait a little bit
for you to arrive
so
tell me in the comments hey bro
tell me in the comments if everything is
looking good to you if the quality is
good is good
so
today what i want to do guys first uh i
want to tell you that i just arrived in
panama guys two days ago i am right now
uh at gabrielle's place so gabriel is
working with me guys on discord i'm
gonna be here for a couple of weeks so i
came here so that i can be on the right
time to do some live trading uh so we're
gonna discuss that today of course hey
morning bro what do you do in hong kong
i'm not in hong kong brother i'm in
panama right now so let me show you a
little bit guys how my setup is looking
so
here we are guys once again i am here at
gabriel's place he's gonna arrive soon
he's at the gym now uh he's gonna be
training all day as well he's a
commodity shredder he's going to take
some big sizes guys so i'm going to
analyze that as well of course with you
um
so what i will do here to start of
course as you guys
want to see some amc and jamie this is
what we're gonna do first
i'm gonna do some analysis on amc on jme
i'm keeping the live stream here so i
can see your questions i'm gonna get
back to that check your questions of
course guys
um
so yeah we're gonna do amcgme technical
analysis then i will show you guys a
little bit how i work i'm gonna show you
my environment i'm gonna take some
trades as well maybe not today because
we need to discuss what you guys want to
see because we can trade some amc or gm
stocks but i know this is a sensitive
subject so we're gonna just discuss that
if you guys want to see me doing that or
not uh i can also trade some uh s p
futures or spy so that it's easy for you
to see what what i'm doing i'm gonna
have a look at the whole market guys
we're gonna keep an eye on of course um
the spy on the oil energy prices guys
um so yeah this is what i want to do
with you today guys
so i can see that you are here
are we looking at bbsg we can have a
look at bbig of course
but like i said i'm gonna start guys
with amc and gme
so
still waiting just a little bit guys
give me
one minute
what's your job bro my job is a trade
again guys i'm an independent trader i
used to work as a professional trader
for seven years you guys already know
that for most of you but i can see some
don't know and right now i just want to
show you guys what i do uh and i want to
transmit the knowledge that i have
acquired so that's why we're going to do
some technical analysis and we're also
going to do some option trading as well
uh because this is a good way i guess to
make money i used to be an option trader
and
and i want to show you the cool things
we can do has the market bottomed we're
gonna discuss that i think we are we
have some reversal signs um
but for now we don't have any strong
signal that the correction is over but
i'm gonna discuss that i'm gonna do spy
i'm still waiting
one more minute guys and i'm gonna start
so i can already go on amc chart guys
we're gonna start with amc then i do jme
guys then i'll have a look at your
questions uh then i'm gonna i'm gonna do
spy
commodity market as well
and then we can talk guys we can talk
like i said i'm gonna show you my watch
list i'm gonna show you the nice
opportunities that i see for today guys
on stocks of course
all right so i start guys i do some uh
usual technical analysis on amc i'm
gonna be quick guys because i want to
have a look at your questions and try to
answer the the questions you might have
so uh first amc guys daily time frame i
didn't do my video this weekend so let's
analyze what we have here so let me
remind you guys the situation that we
have uh we are
uh in a move down since we broke out
from this major triangle pattern guys
all right that was forming since june 21
till here we had this breakout guys that
got followed by a massive move down then
what we are trying to know is uh is the
market ready to reverse and do we have
some signs of reversals i'm gonna
discuss what kind of sand we're looking
for um but i can already tell you we're
looking for a volume increase on uh red
uh green days sorry we're looking for a
breakout we're looking for momentum that
is coming back all right and we also
want to see a low volatility with some
bollinger bands tightening and then
widening because this is another sign of
reversal so here what we have guys as
you know is this downtrend we had this
first breakout that got followed by move
up then rejected
we found some support at 14.5 14.5 guys
is the support that uh i i'm keeping an
eye on for the past month
and
we had some very interesting move
happening last week because we went
below but we came back quickly so let's
analyze what we have here
so once again here we were bullish but
then bears got the best of it and right
now we are moving sideways so it's
already kind of a first reversal sign
whenever we are bearish and then we move
sideways the the macd is able to go
higher so even if the market is just uh
steady not going up or down the macd is
gonna come up guys because it's a
momentum indicator and it means that the
momentum the bearish momentum is going
um is leaving and bulls are slowly
taking back control but
to have a sustainable reversal guys look
what we want to see this is the volume
that i'm
checking here and as you can see we have
decreasing volume here
and we don't have any big uh green days
with strong volume yet okay look we had
one here then we had a move up it got
rejected but we it was the first signal
that buus are trying to take back
control here we had one as well uh and
this was with a breakout so this was
good and here this is again what we're
looking for we're looking for a strong
massive day with so probably a strong
move up but what we absolutely want to
see is a lot of investors implied in the
trade which means that the interest
of investors towards amc is coming back
so this is what we want to see
for now we're not seeing it so we are
neutral here uh we were trading below
14.5 which was bearish but bulls managed
to uh after two days uh come back inside
the above the 14.5 level so i would say
that as long as we're above 14.5 boos
and control in the short term so we
might revisit the 18 level uh 18 is the
first resistance then 21 so i would say
that this whole area guys is an area of
resistance and once again what we want
to see is a breakout above one of those
levels so for now we don't have any
consolidation that is really showing us
a nice uh breakout
area okay this is what we need to see
here maybe we're gonna have one what we
need to have is a consolidation to show
us where the resistance is for now it's
unclear to me if the resistance is 18 21
you know uh we don't have enough data
for now so we need to first uh wait for
this consolidation to appear and then
have a breakout on increasing volume
this is going to be a central reversal
so like i said guys for now i i think
today is quite uh good
because um
because we have uh we came back above
the 14.5 level but uh for now we don't
have any strong reversal sign for the
long term so we are waiting for that
okay let me quickly have a look guys at
your questions and do not forget guys to
give me a like it's important for me
it's helping the channel
um so i see 20 likes guys so thank you
very much for that
so let me quickly read your question has
the market buttoned uh i'm gonna answer
this question of course i don't know but
i'm gonna give you uh my view about that
of course
hello i posted an alert on talo oscar
so
i'm gonna discuss that as well
okay
are we buddhist or bearish very good
question
okay ken sass welcome brother
cool guys thank you so much for your
messages it's really like nice to read
i'm very happy that you enjoyed this i
enjoyed this as well
so
all right i'm gonna do quickly gme but
nobody asks questions about jme right
i'm gonna do jamie later i'm gonna
answer the questions uh in the right
order so
first uh bbig okay i can do bb ag
quickly
because i know there is some interest
about bbig guys
so bam
bbig is not easy guys to analyze let me
be
honest with you because we had a lot of
false signals in the recent past so this
is the situation again i'm using a
logarithmic scale because it gives me
better uh trend lines and a better view
about what is happening guys
so bam bam bam let me get rid of that
okay
so as you can see bbig each time is
moving like that yes we have a move up
and then you know bears keep control for
a long time
uh we have always this kind of trend
line
and then again move up volume increase
and then we move lower so basically
brews are not able to keep the price
action at high levels bears always get
the best of it uh for the past you know
two years and right now we have the same
kind of trend line guys and we had here
a full signal we closed above that and
the next day we got brutally rejected
and bez
really like uh managed to push the price
action much lower so um
this trendline is still good to use
because we have two more reactions guys
as you can see
after that so this trendline is still
good to use
and um
we want to see first oh so look the pre
market is at three so this is looking
good but once again we don't have the
consolidation guys two for a breakout so
here maybe we're gonna break out
um
i don't know i think
let's see what's gonna happen
let's see what's going to happen because
if we open above that level it's pretty
good so let's see if booze managed to
push the press action higher right away
today or not
um
but this is not a strong signal once
again for signal to be good quality you
need to have a consolidation on low
volume before here as you can see we are
just pushing higher strongly so it can
revert any time it is not a strong
sustainable rally i mean it's strong but
it's not sustainable for now to be
sustainable we need to have some support
areas forming just below so that you
know we know that bulls are just waiting
just a little bit below the price action
here the first support area i guess is
that two
so this is the issue i'm having here um
but this is still looking good let's be
honest
next resistance is 420
um
so let's see if we manage to go there if
we manage to go there we're probably
gonna have some kind of little rejection
first and then we will probably uh so
then let's see i don't know what's gonna
happen but we're gonna need to analyze
what is happening here but next
resistance is 420 and if we manage to uh
close above that level which is a strong
uh resistance where bears are definitely
gathered
then guys maybe maybe we're gonna have
this massive moves up like we used to
have uh some time ago
so we need to analyze all of that when
it's gonna come
oh right so hope
and answered the question well guys
okay morning brother
lei who andrew lay who brother
yeah hit that like button guys exactly
okay so
um
i'm going to have a look guys at the
global market we have
the market opening very soon
so
i wanted to show you a bit like what is
happening as well in china because it's
important but let's start guys with
global market let me do some analysis
about the s p 500 so i'm using here the
spy tracker guys
uh so
all right
we are in a correction that's pretty
obvious i mean we were or we are i don't
know but the market corrected
since we had this breakout guys that i
gave you of course in my discord i gave
you that on youtube as well guys this
breakout was a good quality breakout and
on the downside unfortunately and it got
followed by a strong move up okay
usually moves down or move down sorry
usually moves down guys are developing
in three ways as you know
and here
we
um
we can find three waves yes a okay
b
c so the c wave is not complete
but it's still an abc so this first
information uh which is that this
correction already
is containing three legs a b c is
telling me that maybe this correction is
over now whenever the eliot wave
counting is giving you some good
information about uh the potential end
of a correction you need to find some
bullish signals so what are we looking
for we're looking for once again so this
is not a stock so the the volume will
not increase here because on the spy the
volume is trading a lot whenever bears
and control because there is panic there
is fear everybody is training
spy
at this time so here
what we want to see
about the volume is ideally a higher
volume but if we have a steady volume so
here you can see it's steady
so if you have a steady volume on some
uh reverse on some moves ups moves up
this is a goo a good signal as well it's
um it's saying that there are as many
bulls trading the spy right now as they
were when we were bearish and we know
that when we are bearish uh there is a
lot of volume so this is what we want to
see on the volume and especially guys we
want to see this is the most important
thing we want to see some um
the volatility coming down because this
is uh what is going to give us the
information that the correction might be
over so to know what is the volatility
doing guys we need to check the vix all
right so we're going to have a look at
the vix as you can see guys gabriel is
coming back from the gym right now guys
and like i said we're gonna take some
trades today maybe not today maybe
tomorrow because i need to know what you
guys want to see
um but guys it's gonna be amazing i'm
very excited about that once again it's
gonna be for three weeks guys i'm gonna
show you everything we do we're gonna
try different strategies uh and i'm sure
guys that you're gonna learn a lot of
things you're gonna see guys that the
positions that gabriel is training is no
is not a joke yes he's taking big
positions because he's used to that uh
so we're gonna of course have a look at
what positions he's taking he likes to
trade like i said gold um
oil
bitcoin uh all right so we're gonna have
a look at that we're gonna build some
strategies together guys it's gonna be
very cool so let me come back to spy
first
uh
like i was saying yes so
we have so the market is opening pretty
flattish guys right now
uh so we arrive at a resistance level so
like i said here we have some kind of a
breakout okay uh above 4 435 okay you
can see we have a trend line but once
again whenever you have a breakout that
is inclined like here and you don't have
a consolidation before this means that
this breakout might very well uh fake
out okay we're not sure like i said if
we don't have the consolidation just
below the breakout area it means that uh
the consideration is the support area
right and if we if the first
consideration is very low close to the
lows this means that the move down there
is a big risk on a move down because
balls are sitting not very close from
the breakout but much lower so this is
the issue i'm having on the spi right
now uh i'm personally have still a short
position guys on the global market i
reduced it for those who are with me in
this code you know that i did that guys
two days ago i told you that i divided
my short position by two and of course i
have more long position than top
position guys we are buying stocks of
course
um but here yeah let me come back to the
spy analysis so like i said we have this
breakout so this is good quality the
volume is steady which is good for spy
uh the momentum as you can see guys the
macd is uh definitely going higher we
have an rsi on the daily timeframe that
is above 50 which is a good uh indicator
that you can have a look at guys an rsi
below 50 is pretty is basically bearish
of course it's not enough and on rsi
above 50 is bullish right it's a simple
rule it's just like looking at the
20-day moving average if we're above the
20-day moving average we are bullish if
we are below that we are bearish okay we
need of course to associate those
indicators together with some breakouts
and some volume and volatility
indicators but this is a good uh first
information so here you can see rsi is
at 60 guys so 57 so you we can see that
boos are definitely definitely trying
something now the problem having like i
said no consideration around the
breakout area and uh we are coming guys
on the resistance as you can see guys
i'm having this resistance for a very
long time 445 guys it's a resistance
level uh you can see that we have many
reactions guys in the past on this level
and most importantly guys we have the
200-day moving average coming here so
you guys know that on the global market
this 200-day moving average is followed
yes by big money players asset managers
hedge funds you know it's a very
important indicator so this is one more
rule that you can add if we are below
this 200-day moving average on the
global market bears are in control on
the long term and if we're above that
booze and control right so as you can
see guys here we have mixed signals
because we have a breakout but not good
quality the volume is not giving us big
information but rather bullish let's be
honest this volume is nice on this move
up uh the momentum is uh going higher
and rsi above 50 which is good
okay so this is for the bull uh case but
uh guys we have some uh we are below the
200-day moving average we are coming in
the 445 level that has not been tested
for uh guys i don't know more than two
weeks all right last time it was tested
was here so whenever resistance has not
been tested for quite some time it is
usually giving you first rejection so
it's very interesting as you guys can
see right now we are right on this
resistance so i don't know what's going
to happen of course but a rejection
would make sense to me and then we're
gonna see if both are able to get back
to it okay if we see this kind of move
guys this is gonna start to be looking
good all right so here maybe we're gonna
get rejected a little bit not a lot
maybe one percent uh this is the bullish
case i'm giving you okay and then we're
gonna come back to it the second time we
come back to it if it's happening
quickly guys then of course bulls have
more strength more energy because you
know this is what i'm talking about yes
when i talk about consolidation we want
to see a consolidation here right
because this is going to be a bull camp
bull are going to be sitting here ready
to reload ready to buy shares and this
is going to give us good good uh
information about a potential reversal
that can happen for now the bull camp
guys is at 415 all right so okay now
let's say 430 all right fair enough 400
today we have a small boot camp because
as you can see this level gave us many
many reactions in the past month
so but i'm sorry guys uh a bull camp
that is
how far
three percent guys do you want to risk
three percent right now to
uh the next bear camp is
here six percent okay fair enough it's a
risk reward of one to two because if we
manage to close above 450 uh then
we're gonna
we're not having any more uh big um
bearish signs okay because we're going
to be above the 445 level we're going to
be above the 200-day moving average uh
we're going to have bulls that are
really you know taking ground every day
uh once again we're going to keep an eye
on the volume so then if we manage to do
that ideally you guys i would prefer to
see consideration first all right if we
don't see this consolidation i would
personally not buy back my short i will
keep the stroke position but if i have
this consolidation and then i break out
then i will buy back my short position
guys and of course i will let you know
that in this code so it's very
interesting we're coming exactly on the
200-day moving average so we can see how
the market is gonna react to that for
now guys it's gonna you know
it's gonna be i think a nice battle
around this level
uh i'm gonna zoom in later guys and
we're gonna have a look at maybe the 15
minutes time frame of the five minutes
time frame we're gonna try to analyze
what is happening guys on the day and
like i said guys i want to do some day
trading as well with you so this is
going to happen as well maybe not today
[Music]
amc is moving nicely we can also have a
look at that soon so yeah just to
conclude on the global market guys
it's looking great let's be honest i
think this correction might be over but
we still have some
uh bad uh information coming from the
global uh the global outlook is not
perfect yet guys because we have still
the inflation that is not uh
totally handled um
you know the war in russia can of course
evaluate and become uh you know longer i
think this is what's gonna happen so
this can have an impact guys as you know
on the energy prices on the commodity
market and you know that if the
commodity prices are going higher guys
this is going to create more inflation
this is the issue we are having so i
think i'm done for the spy guys bam bam
bam
so let me have a look at your questions
i'm happy to see that a lot of you guys
are
giving me some comments
and you're asking questions yeah x bro
i'm going to talk about x of course we
have something big happening there
so bam bam bam let me show you guys
again we are now
starting everything guys starting the
machine all right and for now guys uh
like i said we're gonna focus on some
analysis but
wait for it you're gonna see some live
trading guys i guarantee that and it's
gonna be very exciting
okay let me take a small break read your
questions
okay
hey trey jimmy please okay you guys
asked i do
i was waiting for that
yeah bro i'm streaming now and like i
said i will be streaming every day guys
from now on um
as long as i'm in panama i guess because
here the connection is good in france i
had a really bad connection so i
couldn't do that and i'm on the right uh
hour to do that
the market is open when i'm awake which
is good of course all right so let me
have a look at gme guys
jme yes we have some you know there were
a lot of things happening guys we got we
had the earnings that gave us a massive
move down and then booze took back
control guess so let me analyze here
what is happening all right so the
situation is pretty similar to what we
had on amc right because
we had this um this strong move down
that was absolute that was very brutal
very violent
uh with high volatility
high volume and whenever you have
something like this guys this is
creating a lot of damage right a lot of
investors are losing money and this is
of course a traumatizing event that
takes some time to repair so time is
necessary whenever we have those strong
moves down with that
big volume because a lot of investors
get trapped it means
unit time so now the time is passing and
we have some early
signals of reversals so once again i
will
recap quickly the situation we had just
moved down and just pretty much in the
same time as for amc guys we had this
breakout here okay
uh this breakout occurred on higher
volume volume after a nice consolidation
guys so keep this in mind i don't know
if you see my screen well i hope you do
uh this is a nice consideration why
because one reaction two reactions three
reactions four reactions five reactions
okay
on
decreasing volume you see so this is a
nice signal so then we had the breakout
on increasing volume okay so this is a
good and reliable breakout it's not
perfect
because the consideration was only
elastic five candles and you know the
momentum was still you know even if it
was going better it was still a bit weak
but we had a nice follow-up to the 130
area okay so it was a nice move up but
then we had
this triangle forming guys and i made a
video when the strangle was forming of
course guys i was uh hoping booze
managed to keep this momentum and have
an upset breakout but i also told you
that if we break out on the dance we'll
probably go back to the 87 level which
happened guys in a matter of a week all
right so
now
we then had a bracket below 87 guys but
so this was bearish definitely and i
made a video to tell you guys that we
need to be very careful because this
area has been each time whenever the the
press action came to this area guys i
remind you that we had some massive
moves with high volatility why because
there was no support but here
okay this is uh trading guys you you can
analyze the past you can of course try
to make assumption but the reality is
always coming back and um and here
the bulls despite the fact that we
didn't have any support in this area
booze managed to take back control in a
matter of three four days so we can see
here we had a huge battle and then this
day guys on friday look at the volume i
told you the volume is important look at
this massive volume so gme opened uh on
the gap down after earnings
the day before
uh
eight eight percent down something like
that guys and what happened a massive
bullish reaction okay booze managed to
bring the price action close to the 100
area and then close above this 87 level
so like i said this 87 level is the
level that we needed to take back this
is now done
uh so
we are now back above 87 so above 87
once again you can see the macd is only
starting to flatten okay so
for now the bullish um momentum is not
really back yet but above 87 we have a
nice consideration as you can see so
this is giving us a good support area
once again because you can see the 87
level guys has been tested five times in
the recent uh past so right now booze
are sitting here to buy okay so uh
just like for nbc guys and just like for
the global market right now the
situation is clearly bullish on the
short term uh we can see uh on gmu names
you didn't have that donald gme we have
the volume increase guys uh that is
happening that happened on friday guys
volume increase after this level look
yes this volume is the biggest volume we
had since what since jan 22 guys so in a
matter of three months it's the first
times bulls traded that many shares
um and managed to once again bring the
price action above the 87 and one why do
you think the volume is so big because
there were a lot of bears sitting at 87
and what happened they got defeated this
is what happened so of course bulls are
back in control uh so like i said 87 is
now support and where is the next
resistance so the the 20-day moving
average is always a level you want to
keep an eye on as you can see guys i
attacked it as resistance here then it
got broken here support here little fake
out support support support support
and now is it might act as resistance so
my take is that we're gonna at least go
test this level around 105 level
uh and then let's see what's going to
happen but as long as we are in the 8715
area we are good
and uh once again guys the big picture
which is important to keep in mind guys
because this is a long term play
uh i'm kee i'm you know doing some
analysis guys on amcgme for almost one
year and we know what we are looking for
guys we are looking for some long-term
strong uh reversal signs right that
could signal a squeeze okay this is what
we're looking for
and
like i said guys i'm repeating that but
i know that all of you are not maybe
watching all of my videos but you know
what is happening right now in the short
term is of course good to keep an eye on
but as you guys know gme and amc stocks
are very hard to uh analyze during
technical analysis because of this
market manipulation guys that is
happening on those stocks you are aware
of that uh but on the medium term the
signals are clearer so um here the
bigger picture
is
that we have a massive massive triangle
that is forming yes
and that is going to give us uh right
now a resistance area around 130 level
all right
and for now it's still far from where we
are guys we're talking about the move of
40 up so we still have time of course
uh but
if we get close to this area guys we
consolidate and once again we're gonna
keep an eye on the option market guys
you know the spreadsheet is very
important let me quickly have uh you see
we were talking about tallow and luke
what do i have here yeah one of you guys
asked me questions about talo and i told
you that i'm keeping an eye on that and
i posted an alert about the stock it's
an energy stock we're gonna come back to
that guys have a look later
for now jamie
okay so i'm retrieving the option market
guys because i know that some of you
maybe you don't understand what i'm
doing here guys but the option market is
a very good indicator of the momentum as
well
it's a very good indicator of you know
how bullish investors are whenever there
are a lot of cool options that i bought
guys
especially if they are out of the money
option why is it not working
do i have my connection well bam bam bam
then it means guys that uh bulls are
back in control okay
all right it's coming
bam
i'm updating the strikes
okay it's gonna come guys it's a bit
slow look look look it's coming so i
just want to show you guys what is the
option market giving us right now on gme
okay let me put
bam bam bam automatic
okay
my spreadsheet is very slow guys i don't
know what's happening here
somehow i cannot retrieve all the value
i wanted but i'm gonna have a look at
that guys i'm gonna fix that and i'm
gonna get back to you with the
information but i can tell you because i
checked recently that for now the
synthetic shot is not big guys uh it's
close to zero but the maximum synthetic
shot is massive all right so um we need
of course to rebuild uh this synthetic
shot so gm needs to go higher call
options closer to the money needs to be
bought and this is as well gonna signal
guys that something is up and i can tell
you guys that i wouldn't be surprised to
see that happening whenever we get close
to this uh trendline i'm personally
gonna start buying call options because
if you wait for the breakout you guys
know that the volatility of corruptions
is skyrocketing and it's a bit late to
buy calls whenever a long-term breakout
occurred especially if it happens on a
high uh on on strong moves so the good
thing is to you know take a little risk
and buy some calls during the
consolidation
so we're going to see how we can do that
with limiting by and limiting the risk
and i can already tell you that it is by
maybe selling a put that is at a support
level like the 87 um put which makes
your strategy a flat premium so i don't
want to make uh things too complicated
right now i'm going to show you guys
that strategy later
so i'm pretty done on on jme guys i sum
up the situation uh booze uh took back
control above uh 87 guys um we have a
consideration just below which is good
uh we don't have the macd going higher
yet we don't have an rsi at 50 yet so
you can see for now we don't have
anything very strong we are moving
sideways
115 is not the 20-day moving average 105
is the first resistance and the next
resistance guys is at 115
all right let me quickly have a look at
your questions guys
okay
for these three likes yes come on guys
hit this like button
give me more likes
okay
so x let me guys show you what i think
of x
because it's interesting
um
how long will your streams be i don't
know i don't know today i think i'm
gonna do one or two hours and then the
idea is just to guys bring you to my
environment show you what i do all day
so then i'm gonna slow down a little bit
the pace of what i'm saying and i'm
gonna focus as well on my job guys on my
work i'm gonna look for opportunities
and i'm gonna try to build some
strategies once again uh we're gonna do
this together with gabrielle guys uh
it's gonna be very exciting so this is
the purpose guys of what i'm trying to
do here with you thank you for the likes
guys i see it's going higher very good
okay so x is exploding i totally agree
so let's have a look at x i posted guys
an alert on x in my discord of course
and i posted uh
yeah and i did a video guys i gave you
this trade uh so x is a steel producer
guys bam plus six percent guys
you know this is a very good quality
breakout so let's analyze this situation
for those who have not watched this
video guys uh you need to see that
because this is the kind of pattern that
we are looking for guys all right so let
me show you this you need to understand
that this is
a good signal guys and i gave you that
on time i even gave you that guys for
those who are with me in discord when we
were training at 23 and this is when i
personally bought call options
and i can explain why so
of course i'm gonna give you targets of
course i'm gonna give you some more
precise tier
but here we gonna first have a look at
the long run okay so look guys
we have since 2
009 i'm here having a look at the 10
year move so i'm using the weekly time
frame of course i could almost use
the monthly time frame but the weekly
time frame is good enough
so you can see we were just going down
guys for 10 years all right and then
this is exactly what i'm talking about
guys when i'm telling you that we need
to have a consolidation look this is
exactly what we want we have a trend
line all right we have a trendline that
is formed by connecting some highs all
right fair enough
then
we can see that here we had a first
reaction on this trend and like i said
guys whenever a trendline has not been
touched for a long time
it's uh it's a strong resistance and you
always i mean not always but very often
have this kind of um
of rejection all right so we had here
one rejection and then guys we have this
nice build up nice consolidation so what
is happening in this area uh we are
above the 200 a week moving average so
you guys can see that this 200 week
moving average here in yellow was acting
very well guys as support so basically
we had bulls that started to buy just
below a resistance so this is forming a
consolidation that is happening with
lower volatility so to know that you
check the bollinger bands and we want to
see them tightening all right this is
the information that we're looking for
okay so as you can see here they are
wide and bam bam bam bam and here they
tighten why because the price is not
moving a lot and let's be honest they're
not very tight but they are tight enough
okay
you can check in the past whenever
they're really tight they can be
tightened all right this is an even
nicer consideration it got followed by a
downside breakout and a strong move down
so this is also the kind of trade you
can make you can buy put options
in this situation but it's not the
purpose of what i'm trying to show you
guys here
so here we had this very nice build up
occurring on
lower volatility the volume was a bit
big that was the only little bad thing
that i saw in this trade but i still got
in there guys um because
it was good enough you know breakouts
are never perfect guys so you you know
that whenever you take a position you
take a risk and here to me the risk was
uh good to take the risk reward was very
nice so
let's go back to what is happening right
now we have this consideration guys and
bam look at that strong breakout with
volume increase and like look the two
past weeks the volume was very low so we
had this lower volume just before
breakout which is showing you guys that
nobody knows what to do nobody is
trading
investors are in a wait and see mode and
then we have this volume increase
with a breakout and look guys what
happened here this is giving you us an
even better signal is that we closed
above the bollinger upper bend guys all
right and this is attracting a lot of
momentum traders all right they keep an
eye on that and whenever we have this
signal uh in a breakout
it just makes the breakout more visible
it's gonna appear on a lot of radars you
know a lot of screeners that are using
this information to select some
breakouts so here we had you know all
the good
ingredients of a good br good and
reliable breakout and look guys we
closed at the top of the week okay so
whenever this happens and i'm explaining
that very well in my course guest for
those who didn't take the course yet
you uh can click on the link in the
description of this video for now there
is no discount yes so uh maybe i'm gonna
add a discount later but uh this trust
me guys that this uh information that
i'm giving you there is
very very precious and uh for those who
are interested
um you're gonna love it you're just
gonna love it and it's gonna help you
guys to understand really how the press
action dynamics are forming and how to
inter interpret this information to take
positions right so um
here i'm explaining in that course that
whenever we have a breakout with a
candle that is closing at the top
of the day or the week here the week
this is showing us guys that um
that booze managed to uh make a clean
victory and so usually there is a
follow-up right away and we don't have
this re-test that is sometimes happening
after this breakouts okay so here we
didn't have this retest we just moved
higher and guess i gave you this alert
here
and
uh bam bam bam
just a sec
let me show you this already guys
okay so this is my discord
then it's a swing alert
i think
just type x
and let me have a look
okay here okay so i gave you this
alright guys when x was turning at 31.4
just on the day on the breakout okay on
the weekly breakout once again i waited
for the end of the week because this uh
was a weekly um
a weekly breakout okay
so bam bam bam now let's talk about
targets guys let's talk about targets
so whenever you have this kind of
situation remember that guys because
this is what i'm giving you guys here is
very very precious if you remember all
of that guys it's gonna be very helpful
for you in training so whenever you have
an incline breakout like that okay let's
get rid of the bollinger bands guys that
up
we see clearer
then what is happening guys let's say 70
80 of the time so of course it's not an
exact science guys you know that
training is about probabilities but
there is a very high probability
that we arrive on the first recent high
okay guys so this is the reason why in
my alert
i gave you a target at
um
at 45 okay because you can see guys that
in this strong move down that lasts for
10 years the first recent high is at 47
and you guys can see that this is a real
resistance because we had here a
rejection and here the price action was
just you know oscillating hovering
around this level so this is the level
where this is the first bear camp bears
are waiting there and i can tell you
that as a bull that i am because i
bought here at 23 i will personally take
profits just a little before
this resistance level because it's it
would be a very nice move up uh you know
times two hundred percent profits so
it's uh good enough to take profits and
then let's see what's gonna happen but
most likely we're gonna get rejected
consolidate a little bit and maybe go
higher all right so here there would be
of course something to do something else
i want to show you guys about x is that
we have a lot of short interest so i
don't know if my short
interest spreadsheet is fixed or not
bam bam
i don't know why it's not working
somehow i'm unable to retrieve the
option market
try normal formula
just to see if it's loaded well let's
just try a normal formula
like a
new new uh excel formula from scratch
like this basic one
i can write this one
okay let me just try to retrieve the
volume
but i have some because i have here the
spot price yeah okay
so some of them are working but not a
lot not all of them
here okay
oh scientific long isn't it spreadsheet
ah no it should be
oh is it
maybe
is it
updated
yeah some of them are not working i
think okay
no but the prime is coming from here all
right
sorry guys we have some technical issues
but this is the job of a trader guys so
let me try to fix it quickly if i cannot
find it quickly yes i will do it on my
side
first
okay i can't retrieve the options guys
okay i'm gonna fix that later there is
some issues with this formula as you can
see sorry about that guys let me get
back to what i was saying but we can see
the regular shot is 17 all right so we
don't have the synthetic shot but you
guys can see here the synthetic short as
the 15th of feb is this let me check if
i have
the
end of months data gas so i was looking
15th of feb
so the next available data should be on
the 25th of feb maybe
on friday
okay it's not available but we have some
short interest this is what i wanted to
show you guys oh right let me get back a
little bit to this so once again bullish
guys now if is it really the time to buy
no guys it's too late if you're not in
this trade uh it's too late yes because
the risk reward as you can see guess
just
you know you know it's very simple to
check if it's worse or not to enter a
trade you just check the target so here
45 you check the level
okay roughly 35 so 10 points and where
is the first support area so we have
some support at 25 so it's already you
can see 10 and 10 so it's a risk reward
of one and are you gonna put your stop
loss at the support no you're going to
put it below you're going to put that 21
right something like that below the
first consolidation
so you can see yes that in terms of risk
reward it's not interesting all right so
i would personally not get in if i was
not there already
alright
so let me have a look thank you guys for
the support i can see the likes are
going higher thank you so much guys it's
very important like i said for the
channel you guys know that this is very
helpful and i'm grateful for that so
x is exploding this is done
damn damn this would be nice yes bro
it's gonna be nice trust me
you guys gonna love what's gonna happen
this three weeks
okay
uh jonas i'm reading a question but i'm
not sure what you're talking about i
don't think we'll retrace to 40
so
x is at 35.
okay i'm not sure
okay then we're gonna come back guys on
the global market guys the market is
open for the past half an hour i'm gonna
show you guys the opportunities that i
see for today as well i'm gonna do this
very soon
i'm gonna show you as well my positions
we're gonna have a look at if i make
money today or not
you guys know that the positions i take
are the positions that i share with you
in this code guys so
of course i take sometimes more
positions because um
because it's not always easy to show you
everything but i'm trying to share with
you the maximum of positions that i keep
open
can am can jamie and amc touch 800 135
where did you get these levels bro
no of course i know those are my levels
guys those levels are still uh are still
here but like i said we need time and
first we need to have this long-term
breakout guys uh so for amc it's about
above 25 roughly and for gme it's
roughly above
um
above 130 all right so as long as we're
below
25 frames 334 gme guys buzz and control
on the long term and we are in the
strangle and whenever we go above that
guys i promise i will be here i will
show you the targets i will analyze uh
everything that is going to happen we're
going to of course have a look at the
option market guys that is key for short
squeeze to you know start this is like
you know the trigger usually for short
squeezes whenever you have those cool
options that are both massively and we
start to get close to the strikes this
is creating guys so much troubles for
market makers and this is what we need
for now we don't have it all right
so we have time and i'm gonna be here to
update you guys whenever we
see this coming back
oh you know okay good question i want to
answer that question guys oil of course
so the first answer is bullish right you
guys know that we have uh you know the
energy prices going higher guys the
first reason let's just put things back
in the context why the energy prices are
going higher guys so the first reason is
that we are in a strong recovery right
for the past two years guys as you can
see you know the the growth is here uh
the business is good guys everywhere
uh you know just this is uh increasing
strongly the demand okay so this is the
first reason for uh the energy prices
going higher so then this was before
guys now you guys know that there is a
war all right so this is
uh the community the oil price futures
so 108.7
right now
this is interesting thank you for this
question because i wanted to discuss
that
and you guys if you are interested in
what is happening if you if you are
taking positions on the market you need
to keep an eye guys on the community
prices because it's a very good
indicator of the health of the economy
guys it's showing you if you know what
is um
if there is demand if you have some you
know supply chain issues for example
that could create inflation things like
that okay so
once again weekly chart guys uh i'm here
uh pam pam pam guys
making some analysis since 2008
oh right and as you guys can see
a little bit like x
okay
so let me put this trendline it was good
like that before
okay i'm i'm going to use this trendline
all right so starting in april 2011 once
again guys some tips i'm giving you
right now guys so listen to that it's
very important whenever you draw your
lines what you need to pay attention to
is you you need to maximize the number
of reactions okay maybe you were aware
of that but think about this uh
differently
uh i mean you need to maximize the
number of reactions but especially in
the recent past so here for example i'm
missing this
point okay true but i don't care this
was uh in 208 and i prefer to match this
one two three four four reactions in a
more recent past so this is a much
better trend line than the one i was
showing you before uh which i was not
using by the way i just started to do it
a bit
mechanically
but the streamline is good so we have
four reactions and then what is
confirming guys that the streamline is
gonna give you reactions is whenever
once again guys i'm repeating that but
this is very important you need to
absolutely keep that in mind guys
whenever you trade those consolidation
areas that are forming whenever they're
forming it means that there is a bear
camp okay there is a resistance all
right if you prefer and we can see that
here
uh
this trendline was of course
visible for you know the past seven
years eight years and then we have some
rejections at 94
right one two three four and guys same
thing i gave you this breakout guys then
here we had a breakout above this level
um
and and i told you that you can check
the video i did guys two three two weeks
ago i told you guys we're gonna go
higher and we're gonna get rejected why
because this consideration is not very
long it only lasts three candles for ten
years more it's not a good consideration
so whenever the concentration is not
long enough
usually there is a retest okay so here
we moved higher but massively all right
this was you know because of the war all
right there was some events that were
making this move very strong guys
and then as expected we got rejected all
right we got rejected and this is the
reason why you want to trade breakouts
after consideration because we had here
even if it's only a three candles
consideration it's still a good enough
consideration boos were gathered there
and guys in my discord once again i gave
you so many energy trades guys last week
so
we can quickly have a look
we bought some baba as well so cs guys
first they were all coming back to
support levels all right so we had cs
that is looking good guys you can have a
look uh i'm not sure if we are um close
to the m3 levels or not btu tallow you
can see so re-testing the breakout
levels so uh i'm going to do talo
because there was a question about that
but what i want to show you guys is that
this is all related all right you keep
an eye on the oil uh this is very a good
very good indicator to use for the
energy stocks and whenever you see that
oil is coming back to support and you
see the energy stocks are coming back to
support as well this is giving you a
hint that
bulls are gonna buy all right and this
is what happens so personally um so i
sent you a lot of alerts i personally
bought some collapsions on uh the oil
market guys i used the uso etf guys
which is very good a very good proxy for
the oil
market
so right now let me give you my view
because i explained to you how you do uh
how you trade this kind of situation but
now let's
finish this analysis and i will show my
view guys so
we got the bullish reaction at 100 and
guys this is a long term breakout so
just like for x guys you look for the
recent highs and here
they already got touched guys the recent
high was at 115 okay so that's why this
was my target before
and the next one is 145 so
this is a long term breakout once again
so
it might happen guys in three months in
six months in one year i don't know when
but it's gonna happen uh i mean
technicals are uh all pointing in the
same direction is that oil is gonna
trade at 145 at some point probably
before you know deck 23 so one or two
years all right
um so we have time
uh probably this is gonna be depending a
lot on the situation between russia and
ukraine yes because you know that if
this conflict this war is lasting long
this is gonna put pressure on the
commodity prices but then we also have
china that is entering in the game so
they're fearing u.s sanctions but let's
be honest they are happy to buy
i mean a russian commodity at a lower
price right so this is also going to be
a good information uh we also have for
now some strong labor market in the us
we still have growth of course the
growth is going to be impacted by the
war but we still have growth so we're
still going to have demand so this is
going to keep impacting the energy
prices um and
and the war is still going to impact the
energy prices i mean we have all the
reason to believe uh fundamentally
speaking that the energy prices are
going to keep increasing and i can tell
you guys i'm talking about that with
um many friends
i have some friends once again in uh at
google sacs in different banks
working on the commodity market
everybody has the same view everybody is
bullish so everybody can be wrong of
course guys all right i'm not saying
this is going to happen for sure i'm
just saying that professionals have all
positions that are bullish on oil and i
can tell you as well that gabriel who is
once again guys sitting here with me he
is taking positions guys uh on the uh
oil market he made a lot of money with
that uh in the past two three weeks guys
uh and
and he's bullish as well so i mean i
don't know anyone that is you know
working close to the professional
environment that is the professional
trailer
and that is not bullish on the energy
prices alright so i think this view is
very um
is very legit and technicals are
confirming that guys all right so
i think my answer was
complete enough
okay
so i'm gonna have a look at your
questions guys
[Music]
okay
bam so
i want to show you my watch list guys
okay so i think i'm going to do that
right now and it's going to be very
interesting as we're going to discuss
breakouts so once again guys this
is the best technique that you can use
to make money you know it's not easy
okay let's be honest it requires a lot
of knowledge
a lot of time you need to you know pay
attention to what is happening on the
market you need to know what is a good
and reliable breakout so i want to show
you some examples guys then i'm going to
take your questions of course then we're
going to discuss what you want to
discuss guys but first let me show you a
little bit how this is working this is
my environment guys so here i'm having a
watch list okay so i'm having here a
column with alerts all right so you can
do whatever you want but you need to
find a way to every day find some
opportunities so the best way guys is to
join my discord all right because i'm
sharing that there but if you don't want
to join my discord find a way you can
use some screeners but you need to be
good at coding uh or you can just do
some basic things guys like i'm doing
you know i'm just putting the level so
here as you can see guys i have all my
stocks all right so i'm keeping an eye
on many different stocks
okay let me just put back the battery
okay and i have some levels
that i put here
bam bam bam
that i call bid one
and i want to monitor whenever a price
is coming close to this level so this
level is entered manually so let me
check for example the last one
i had
i don't know so for example talo okay so
i'm going to do talo okay so taro is
here
and i was monitoring
a breakout
above 15 okay and whenever this happens
i have some formula that is creating an
alert all right so here as you can see i
have a one that is telling me that talo
is close to 15 and i entered this
manually so i'm showing you that yes
because it's very easy to do and
everybody can do that as long as you
have the stock price and you know a
little bit how to use excel okay
so
okay
so as you can see i i'm having this uh
in my screen for uh which is not a
screener by the way but in my watch list
for quite some time
bam bam bam
and as you can see guys here
uh we have
this downtrend right so whenever you
have a down trend as usual guys you
connect the highs and you're looking for
a breakout so here we are to break out
above 15 so this is the reason why i had
15 as level to watch so i'm just showing
you a little bit how this is working so
let me quickly analyze talu and then i'm
going to show you the opportunities i
see today
um so bam bam bam here classic situation
guys breakout without consolation so uh
weak breakout but with volume increase
after low volume uh and we get rejected
at the first recent high guess so you
know if i'm saying that it's because
it's something i see happening very
often and it happened here you got
rejected as at the first recent high
that was at 18
here
and then we got uh back to the support
area all right on the trend line to
retest the streamline around 14.5 so
here i sent an alert guys once again so
i send an alert for nine and where is
talo bam so buy at 15 i said okay
and it was trading at 14.8 okay
so right now so basically here and i
explained right now the reason behind is
that we came back to the breakout area
and bruce that couldn't buy before at 15
like me because this breakout was too
brutal i'm happy to get in at the same
level i would have bought if i was you
know training the breakouts during the
breakout but now i have the information
better because i have two candles that
close above that level which is
confirming that bulls are back in
control all right so here there was a
nice trade to do i'm bullish guys on
tallow and especially because i'm
bullish on the oil market i show you
guys the analysis i did on the oil all
right so now we are we are at 109 okay
so we can very well be rejected and get
back to 92. true true totally true but
then talo will get back to the support
level so buying talon now
is not
very risky i mean of course it's risky
but the reward is very nice because it
can next time it's going to go to 18
my take is that we break it all right
because the second time a resistance is
touched it's get weaker and the next
level is 31 so talo can very well take
100 percent and how much you're going to
risk for that okay if you want to be
conservative you put your stop-loss at
12. all right what did i show you guys
in my alert and i'm sorry by the way for
those who are with me on discord if you
get pissed that i'm sharing those
outlets but i think it's interesting to
show everyone those
alerts even if they are a bit late so
that everybody can understand what we do
here and and yeah i think it's pretty
interesting for you to um to know what
is happening and how uh
pro traders actually working guys so
this is uh i i i
so this is how we actually build our
trades and buy at 12 so you see i was
very conservative on this one by 15 by
12 stop loss nine all right because i
know that the oil market can pull back
but even if it pulls back it's probably
going to get both for the fundamental
reasons that i told you before all right
so here we can go maybe to this level so
here you buy more right so tallow for
those who are interested
it's still time to get in not financial
advice of course guys but um this is
a good trade idea that i'm giving you uh
it's still time to get in it's better to
keep some um
some position to buy more around those
moving averages guys that are located
between
12 and 12.5 that's why i said by 12
again stop-loss guys around the first uh
recent law so here so a very
conservative stop-loss so you take a big
risk because you can lose uh roughly
13.5 minus nine so 4.5 points but how
many you can make you can make 15. all
right so risk reward one two three this
is a good trade idea and once again
the fundamental reasons are here guys
okay
so i think answered tallow so now i want
to show you so i explained quickly how
the um how my watch list is working and
now i'm just gonna click like every day
guys for those who are with me in this
code this is actually how i get my
alerts all right i just click here and i
select the alerts column all right and
bam those are the alerts i have today so
i wanna go with you through those alerts
so there are a lot of them
but we're not gonna do all of them
because of course i know what is here
and some of them are more interesting
than the others so
you can see bbig is in the alert guys
okay
and i put
so i'm starting to keep an eye on bbig
at 365 if we get close to that level uh
i'm gonna start to be interested in what
is happening here
for now we are below so i wait all right
so talo is in the alerts so let's do
them guys from top to bottom all right
so d e
d e guys i gave you this trade as well
but let's be honest uh he did a lot of
ups and down and i personally got
stopped so this is the risk all right
but now the breakout is very clean guys
okay
so i'm actually a bit late guys i should
have bought yesterday but you know i
arrived in panama i was working on uh
setting up everything um
and
yeah yesterday was friday by the way so
you know i couldn't buy i was in the
plane so whatever here guys this is a
good situation look
uh it's still time to get in
okay
not financial advice of course guys but
look look
what we have here
we have
a strong move up okay
bam and then a consolidation guys all
right so you start to know that this is
what we're looking for we have a
consideration so we don't really care
guys about the elliot with counting here
even this one is pretty correct
okay
and then
so we had this consideration here we had
a fake out on the downside okay it
happened i personally got stopped here
so you see you can do good analysis but
still got stopped it happens
uh it's part of the game all right so
here we have the strong move up
consolidation and now guys this
consideration on the upside is very nice
because as you guys remember i told you
that the most recent past is the most
important guys okay so here in the very
recent past we had one two three four
five six seven okay seven reactions in
the very recent past and two reactions
a bit uh older then we have here a
breakout do we have an increase in
volume okay we don't have it so you see
this breakout is not perfect
this breakout is not perfect perfect
because for breakout to be good quality
here you we can see this is the first
time we trade above this trend line at
400
but it didn't happen on increasing
volume all right as you guys can see
here
this
uh green bar is
smaller than the red bar before all
right
so
this is showing you that there is a big
fight between bows and bears and that
even if right now booze and control
bears didn't let it go yet because they
won a big battle
two weeks ago so
you know they are still confident and
there they can very well
you know push the price action lower so
here i wouldn't buy right now but if we
get back to the 400 level this is a good
opportunity right because we can very
well have whenever breakout is not
perfect it
increases the privacy of retest and by
the way guys this is what i'm explaining
in my course and as it's my first stream
guys i will make something special for
you i will add the discount guys just
for today uh because you know i cannot
talk about this course and uh just tell
you that the breakout
that the uh price is um is still higher
so i will reduce the price only for
today yes for those who here if you want
to take the course so that we can you
can follow better what i'm talking about
um
but let's go back to what i was saying
hey guys here
on de and the link is in the description
of this video yes so just wait a bit
after the live and i'm gonna add the
discount uh is uh
just for one day okay so bam here
uh
like i said if your breakout is not
perfect it is usually retested so we can
go
uh we can go back to the 400 support
area
and then um
and then we can very well guy push
higher we have a lot of room on the
upside
uh let me check again quickly
ge i think
i forgot what they do
i think it's an energy stocks
and okay
okay agricultural agriculture rule
construction forestry and commercial and
consumer equipment
companies are pleasure basement parents
[Music]
okay so they are doing a lot of
different things so basically this is i
think um
this stock price is impacted by you know
the global
economy okay if the global economy is
good they're going to be able you know
to sell well their things
agricultural this is a little bit
related to what is happening with the
war but not that much construction okay
they are they're relying a lot on uh the
global
uh economy health okay so if we are good
they're gonna do good this is pretty
much what i'm getting from this
information
so
yeah this is a good opportunity i think
so i did de guys uh what else do we have
okay i'm not gonna do all of them
bbig guys uh we've done that before
fiscal days okay fiscal is interesting
let me show you fisa
uh fiscal is an energy stock but there
is a lot of short interest and i know
that you guys like
stocks with a lot of short interest so
let's have a look at v7
alright
so as you can see guys weekly timeframe
because it's a long-term move and look
what we're having here it's very
interesting okay and i can tell you that
this guys i'm gonna be here don't worry
for those who are with me on discord
you're gonna receive the alerts on time
okay i'm keeping a i'm keeping an eye on
this one so we had a nice move up guys
that started in june 19 okay we went to
the third
level roughly and then we corrected once
again guys you know that corrections
usually
happen in three waves all right
and here we can count three waves so
it's not enough to say the correction is
over but it's just one information that
we keep in mind then
look in this correction what is
happening so let's have a look at the
volume
so the volume
is decreasing all right so this is the
first good information of a reversal
like i said guys we need to find balance
between bulls and bears before
one of those camps
is taking back control so here bears
were in control we but we see the move
down is you know out of steam out of
energy because the volume is lower right
so it's basically turning less so then
it's easier for bulls to come in
in the trade and they don't need to buy
that many shares you know to um
to beat the bears and here this is what
happened and we can see that we have
this breakout that happened but no
volume increase so it was a risky one so
i didn't give you that trend guys
and then we started to move higher and
we came close to the resistance area
okay
so as you can see
as usual guys we connect the highs and
we want to see a consolidation okay so
here we can see that we got rejected
once twice and now three times yes it's
already three candles it's starting to
be interesting all right we have a
consideration okay so pretty much the
consideration is between the 580 level
and the seven seven level all right so
between 520 and seven yes we have this
consideration so buying around
five
uh sorry is it 520
580 sorry guys so around 580 it's a nice
support area to uh start to build up
some long position and we're waiting for
a breakout and once again this is one
what i'm monitoring but guys it's easier
to have a good and reliable breakout
whenever you have this volume lower
because as you know we need to have a
volume increase but it's much easier to
have a volume increase after low volume
right so we are in a very good situation
guys so once again i'm keeping an eye on
that and i want to see a
seven level roughly and close around 7
10 720 would be perfect and if this
happens guys what's gonna happen i think
is as usual guys we're gonna revisit the
recent high get rejected and then we're
gonna see but probably bullish fraction
alright so keep an eye on that guys i'm
gonna keep an eye of course uh on this
one for now nothing to do
if you want to trade the build up not
financial advice but 580 is a good level
to buy uh with a stop loss around you
know five to 580 sorry is a good level
to buy with the stop loss just below
guys so roughly 5 30 520 all right
something like that
okay
and you see guys spy what i told you
guys i told you we're going to get
rejected at 446 and this is what is
happening all right so it was kind of
expected if i was doing live training
here guys i would have sold here so
easier said than done i know but trust
me guys we're gonna do that together
soon uh yeah by the way let me know
right now guys in the comments
it's important to me to know if you want
to see me uh
trading amc and gme guys
live all right they trade those stocks
because i know those two legendary
stocks yes i have a lot of respect for
them uh and i don't want to do something
that you guys don't want to see me doing
so tell me right now guys you can tell
me in the chat i'm going to keep an eye
on that but tell me in the comments as
well so i can get back to it and uh and
have a look guys all right
so bam bam bam
so i'm waiting to see guys do you want
to see me day training amc and jimmy or
not all right if i don't i will go to uh
you know spy i will go to gold to oil to
other stocks all right and when i say
day trading guys it's gonna be you know
some open positions so there's gonna be
some buying and some selling and i don't
want once again guys
to um
you know to annoy some of you by selling
amc yes daytrade amc good idea okay
but be prepared guys to see me selling
you know this is the issue because apes
don't sell right but if i do day trading
on amc guys i cannot only buy all right
i need to take profit sometimes
otherwise it's not day training all
right otherwise it's just accumulating a
long position which is a different game
but this is not what i want to show you
guys
so um
okay
so for now i have only one comment so
for now i consider the consensus is
pretty
up for it
so i will i will do it guys i will do it
i will show you how it's working
okay
so guys i'm gonna open my portfolio
in front of you guys i don't care
i want to see a little bit oh i'm mad
hey brother here you go
yes please go ahead okay so i i don't
see anyone that is against the idea
uh okay but do you prefer me to do amcgm
or do you prefer me to do maybe spy or
you know all of the stuff i mean i will
do that anyways because it's interesting
but what do you want what do you really
want me to do guys because i'm doing
that for you you know that
so
let me know okay
okay so let me connect
let me put that here guys
we're gonna have a better view
gold
okay
so
you can't
nice
nice you guys can see here what we are
doing guys
we are you know working on nfts by the
way so those are the new designs we are
having
so i don't know if you see it well guys
but it's gonna be very very cool
we are building that guys this product
is gonna be amazing guys i can tell you
and we are
you know we're just gonna make something
epic guys like i said about those nft so
by the way for those who are interested
guys to know more about what we do there
with those nfts guys join the discord
description the link is in the
description join the twitter guys
retweet our pin comment uh you know
invite your friends your family you guys
help us grow on this project it's going
to be amazing
uh what we really want to do guys for
this project is
you know to do some crypto arbitrage so
gabrielle that is sitting here guys is
making a lot of money guys on some
crypto arbitrage and we want to share
this knowledge with you guys of course
we're not gonna give you the knowledge
because it's too complicated to do even
i personally don't know how to do that
um but gabriel knows he made a lot of
money guys doing that so we want to give
uh some uh to to to basically share the
money we're gonna make with this fans
once again depending if the um sec is
allowing us to do that because there are
some uh restrictions about that so we're
gonna have a look at everything guys but
this product is gonna be epic if this is
not working we're gonna do something
else uh so basically guys you need to be
a part of it guys so i'm waiting for you
there so let me just validate yes sorry
i'm gonna turn off the webcam quickly
okay
sorry one second guys stay with me stay
with me did not receive the notification
we maybe have something for you guys
okay
wait wait wait
and give me more likes guys 74 likes i
want to reach 100 likes guys hit that
like button if you enjoy what is
happening
okay guys so we have right now a crypto
arbitrage live guys so let me explain to
you how it's happening so maybe i'm
gonna uh so first let me
put back the webcam
okay so stay with me guys so gabriel
sitting here just told me guys that we
have live a crypto arbitrage so gabriel
tell us what is happening uh so
basically i'm monitoring several
exchange and right now basically what we
have is uh asm
a token on coinbase
and uh asm on gate io where basically uh
right now you see there is kind of like
here you can see the price is basically
0.52 cents this is here
is basically 0.54 cents
and basically uh what my algo is doing
right now is basically selling on this
exchange
and basically buying on this one
i have basically balance you see here my
balance here i have basically okay
number balance no i'm not vlogging here
so it's not showing you but basically
my my goal is to automatically
selling on this one buying on this one
and when i'm gonna dry out my um
my balance of asm on this gate iowa
exchange
is i'm gonna have my balance of uh
coinbase automatically sent to the
to get io so what you can see here in
the field
uh is basically like right now doing
some field progressively
i can show that by that time uh like a
few seconds ago so basically a few
minutes so he's basically doing this
from an automatic basis
buying all those asm on
on coinbase
and basically selling it here let me log
in uh let me give you a minute for me to
log in and show you the sale on the
other side but basically that's what he
is doing okay guys so let me just for
those who just have seen what we told
you guys here i know it's new for you
it's maybe a bit uh not straightforward
guys uh let me desume but basically you
can see that the crypto um the
cryptocurrency market guys uh is a very
complex market we have different
exchanges and the prices among the
exchanges are different all right so
whenever we spot a price that is higher
on one exchange and lower on another one
gabrielle created once again some
algorithm to monitor that and right now
we have some uh something so basically
his bots are gonna buy and sell in the
same time guys uh this
uh cryptocurrency and locking the
profits
all right guys so we're gonna let you
know once again when during the day we
have some things happening so uh bam bam
bam let me get back to what we were
saying guys
so i wanted to take quickly my portfolio
so bam what do we have so i'm making
some money all right it's good so as you
can see i'm in x guys
uso okay so oil is doing good
uh so
okay so basically
roku is going down but i saw i bought
shares but i sold calls as you can see
on the roku for example i'm not uh i'm
not losing uh much money i have my short
position on a nasdaq that is giving me
some protection here guys as you can see
making 270 dollars here 100 here
all right my positions on baba guys that
gave me a very good position and here i
sold some calls like i told you guys on
baba right so i'm i have shares and i
sold a june 173 call all right guys so
this is the positions i'm having right
now and i'm of course gonna add some
positions uh with you
uh
whenever we see some nice opportunities
so let me quickly have a look guys at
your questions
okay
so
amazing bro exactly appreciate button
guys in french for my french guys that
are here and i still that still didn't
hit that like button guys
smash it give me some likes
and bam bam bam
let me go back guys to my watch list
so we saw fisel guys so fisel once again
if we close above seven guys remember i
can tell you that something is gonna
happen all right because we have this
nice uh situation okay
x of course is in the radar guys all
right so x we had the breakout above 28
here okay here is the breakout column
that i'm monitoring all right
just for you to understand
then okay
nrp guys nlp guys is just you know going
higher and higher and higher
but
the breakout occurred at 23.
so nothing much to do here
i want to do a stock that is interesting
so we have this one qs yes i can have a
look at that
dt i gave you that stock already talo is
here nine is here okay we're gonna do qs
guess qs is a company that is creating
uh some
new technology batteries right so
this is a very promising company guys
but they are not making money yet but
you know
uh they can make some money all right so
in the future if the ev
sector is doing well because once again
we need those better batteries guys
because you know that this is the main
issue that the ev sector
is having right now is that those
batteries guys they sometimes they take
you know um
they um it takes time to recharge the
energy and they're not lasting long
enough so if you have batteries yes that
can last i don't know 10 hours right
this would be just uh you know a very
good
thing for the sector so the companies
that are working on that guys maybe
they're not gonna succeed but if they do
guys this is going to the moon all right
so i'm keeping an eye on that and we are
having here so i'm talking about qs guys
quantum
scape okay
so um
i think it's interesting to keep an eye
on this one
because once again guys
as you can see so we're on a move down
okay so whenever you have a move down
what are we looking for we're looking
for reversal signs so volume volatility
momentum okay guys stay with me i'm
gonna explain how you uh check all of
that all right so
we have here
uh bam bam
a move down so let's first check just
basically the volume what is the volume
doing and then let's try to analyze this
information
uh
not much information guys here as you
can see the volume is pretty low but
rather decreasing okay since here
so for now this is telling us yes that
we are in a situation especially here we
have those low volume guys trading it's
like the lowest volume we had for you
know the past year
uh so whenever volume you you can see
the price action stopped moving down
that 14 is moving sideways for the past
three weeks
uh three months even let me go on the
daily timeframe i was on the weekly time
frame
okay it's even clearer here and we're
having guys here this consolidation that
is happening actually the weekly
timeframe was good guys and once again
in my course guys i tell you what time
frame you should use because here for
example you can see i'm switching from
daily to weekly and uh basically the
rule um i like to apply is that you know
for two three months correction you can
start to use the weekly time frame
uh i mean four months maybe so here we
have three months so we can start to
have a look at the weekly timeframe
because it's giving signals that are
maybe delayed but that are more trustful
okay more reliable so here
we can see we are moving sideways
close to the lows all right same
situation as for gme some situations for
mc so whenever this happens look at the
macd
the macd is flattening and then starting
to move up rsi is still below 50 so we
are definitely not bullish yet bursting
control so you don't want to buy now
especially we don't have any volume
increase but i'm gonna keep an eye on
this because we're in a good situation
because now if we have a strong move up
so i'm going to tell you about which
level
uh but the rss probably going to go
above 50 the macd is going to be
increasing definitely and if you have
this volume increase guys this would be
a good reversal signal but once again
for the signal to be good we need to
find a consolidation area above which we
break out so it can be inclined it can
be horizontal here as you can see i have
two of them
but this one has been crossed already
the breakout occurred all right or above
the stream line but without volume
increase okay so it's not a good signal
because it can very well be rejected
bulls won a battle but the bears were
not involved all right so you know bears
are still here they didn't lose money so
they are ready to you know fire back and
just push the push the press action
lower so it's too early to consider this
as a signal but
uh what is interesting is that we came
back to the this level i guess this
what is this level the 18 level roughly
what did i put in my watch list
my watch list i put 17 because i want to
see it early but the truth is that i
will not send an alert before 18 on that
but if we close above 18 with a daily uh
with a weekly increase volume increase
we would start to be looking good guys
and
and we might very well you know go to
the 40 area that would be the first
resistance here
i mean the first resistance would be 20
but when it would not probably hold gas
because because as you can see soka 20
is the natural uh the overhead
resistance but look at how many
reactions we had okay we had five
reactions here but it was gas in
september 21 six months ago and here as
you can see guys it's pretty obvious
that the um the battle is happening here
right so if you defeat bulls at 18
i mean they're all gathered here they're
not that many bulls at 20 all right once
again this is my analysis i might be
wrong but if i was a bear i wouldn't i
wouldn't wait 20 i would take position
at 18 because i would be with the other
bears all right because you don't want
to be alone in your trade right you need
to find where is your camp and you need
to fight together with them this is what
is happening in trading guys alright so
this is uh how i personally like to do
my trades and here definitely it's
17.5 18. all right this is the level to
take back if you close above that guys
the rest is gonna be um
like a knife in the battle not sure i
can say that in english but it's an
expression saying it's gonna be easy all
right
so
uh so i'm keeping an eye on this one
once again we need volume increase and a
move above let's say let's say 18 let's
be safe all right
okay
so gabriel is now telling me that he is
starting to make his trades today uh but
the first trade he's doing is a
butterfly on some commodity guys a
butterfly is uh you know a complex
strategy using co-options
okay so it's butterfly spread guys so
it's even you know it's different it's
not an option
ah but the fact is basically is
basically i said i basically buy two
features say for example uh the may
and september okay and i sell the
the future in the middle
okay so let me explain uh for those who
uh who want to to understand that
basically he's playing um you know the
curve the so basically it's a calendar
position so he's going to use an asset
he's going to buy and sell for example
uh
different maturities of this asset so
different forward prices on the curve
once again guys i know it might seem
complicated but this is real training
yes this is how you make money
let me give you an example let's say
let's say crude oil let's assume crude
oil crude oil is a is a commodity so
basically
you have deliverables so basically when
you buy a future usually it's like i
mean usually you want to be delivered
the crude oil
um and except if you basically sell your
position before uh the expiry you're
gonna actually get deliver the credit
so you have features for different
expiry
so let's let's call it for example let's
make it simple may june july
and usually you have different prices
for these different expiries
but let's make it simple for now and
let's assume that for these three
expiries the price is 100
okay this is the price as of yesterday
and that you think this is a fair price
but then let's say that tomorrow
this curve move and let's say that may
and july doesn't move they're still at
hundred dollar
but the june for whatever reason you
don't know is going at 110
i'm just making an example like that
it's not gonna happen this one
let's make it simple then you're gonna
say well it's abnormal the curve should
not do this so
i'm gonna buy
the may and july at hundred
and i'm gonna sell the june 110 but i'm
gonna sell it twice
and basically what you what you're
betting is that the curve of this future
is gonna come back to normal where the
price that is right now in june at 110
will come back at 100 or
that the may
or end of july will move say at 105 or
110 and at the other one will basically
go back to 105. okay can you show us an
example because i know that this guys i
know it's complicated but once again
guys this is how you make money in
trading yes this is what he was using
when he was in a bank do you have maybe
uh some can we see the curve i can see
we can see the curve but the thing is uh
if i show you to be fair because
it's gonna be very difficult to see i
can't show you okay okay for now it's
very difficult to see because it's not
in the same proportion if it was in the
same proportion i mean everyone would be
making so much money right
so
you have this but it's not first it's
not in the same market like what i'm
doing now is not incredible it's in uh
actually a pork market because pork
market pork because this is what do you
mean pork market he's telling the pork
market guys
okay okay because uh like where you
usually have more the most opportunity
in commodities is in market where there
is
fuel liquidity basically because you
have less people watching at it so you
basically have prices that do
they don't move like as they should move
because there is not
actual liquidity there is not enough
people that locate to basically make the
the price
uh
efficient let's put in this yeah so let
me recap the situation so basically you
guys understand that the community
market is using some forward curves all
right so you have different points on
the forward curve right the may forward
is not going to be the same price as the
airport forward for example and for some
reason sometimes uh you have a
discrepancy that is happening guys on
this curves and this is creating some
opportunities all right so this is what
we call to play a spread alright so uh
once again i don't want to make it too
complicated you guys especially for the
first time but uh i'm gonna try to you
know show you clear examples of what
uh what he's doing guys and i can tell
you that he's making money guys you know
for quite some time he always made money
guys when he was working the bank and
now he's a prop trader guys using his
own money and look at this place guys
this was both guys with this money i
mean not both but what i mean is that
this is the real way to make money okay
and i want to share that with you so of
course i'm going to show you what you
guys want to see on stocks but it's
going to be very interesting guys for
you to see the other strategies that
exist in trading and that are used by a
lot of shadows that are successful right
because uh not that many trades are
successful guys and whenever someone is
successful you always need to ask
yourself why why is he doing differently
why is this working right and i'm gonna
explain to you guys uh as much as good
as i can everything here i mean if you
want to have an example it's not the
best but i can't this is the trade i'm
doing right now okay
okay so right now we have an example
guys so uh once again stay with me guys
uh and uh try to understand that okay so
look this is a curve so explain to us
what is it gabriel okay so basically
this is uh the pork market for the month
of april
so i would be like this is by april
by august so j is april okay so this is
a okay so this is a bit of less spread
so this is the difference so the the
curves you see the different curves you
see is uh the difference between the
forward uh prices of the meet uh the
poke market all right this is basically
buying april
buying august or plus plus and selling
june two times okay and
each line represents a year so um i'm
color blind but basically
uh i think this kind of yellow thing
represents 2021
like i don't see the
like basically the different curve
different ears and basically one thing
right now in black this is this year and
what we can see is that the price of
this structure this butterfly
is really low compared to average okay
so i'm going to sum up guys basically
you can see different curves so what i
can tell you guys is that this is what
it's relying up on you basically buy
what is undervalued all right and then
you just wait for things to be back to
normal so uh
so uh this is the the the different
things you can do and right now guys
let's go back on stock market and uh
let's see what
what else we have guys what are other
opportunities we have so okay cool man
okay so tell us in the comments guys if
you enjoyed this kind of content because
i can see that uh the viewers have
dropped a bit that's why i'm gonna go
back guys to the equity market but guys
we're gonna make it simple for you to
understand and uh let me know if you're
interested to see that once again i know
it might seem complicated yes but this
is how you make money in trading all
right so
let us know in the comments guys what
you think of that we're gonna make we're
gonna find a way to make it easy for to
you friend for you to understand because
right now i know it might seem
complicated guys but this is uh
but this is what is happening all right
so let me have a look at your questions
guys let me
give you what you want to see
okay i've been doing more multi-leg
options so we have a client here right
and i have a question i've noticed some
cool butterfly okay cool david's hold
positive delta theta and gamma how would
you evaluate an option like that alright
so
usually when you do a butterfly you uh
should not have depending on where you
put your strikes but you do you should
not have uh exposure on
let me show you guys a butterfly okay
i'm gonna show you a butterfly on uh on
stock okay so i'm here having baba for
example okay so let's do baba
okay
i'm gonna show you what is a butterfly
guys and i'm gonna show you how
okay what kind of strategy you can make
so
uh baba is right now trading at
okay so i go on baba by the way let me
go quickly
do up bam so i gave you guys an alert on
baba to buy at 88 and 73 75 guys and we
you can see that we bought them at 73
and then we had a plus 37 percent move
up guys massive move up so right now uh
baba is get back to 110 so uh bulls took
back control in the short term but let's
see what is gonna happen on the medium
term but i'm gonna show you guys here a
strategy an uh option butterfly because
if you uh if you ask questions about
that i think um you might be interested
so uh basically when you play a
butterfly on options it means that you
bet that the press action will remain at
a certain level
at a given time so let's say 110 i think
it's a pretty fair uh target all right
let's say for june 22 110 because you
can see we have a support here support
here support here resistance resistance
so basically this level is acting a
little bit like a magnet and the
probability we stay around this level is
higher than any other levels all right
just because once again guys there are a
lot of buyers and sellers around this
level so the price action is attracted
to it okay
um so let's say that we want to play the
fact that baba is turning 110 in june
then uh you gonna for example
uh buy
and we're gonna use 130 and 85 as the uh
the legs of the butterfly okay so we're
gonna have a piano like that this is
what we want we want to
lose a little bit of money above 130
lose a little bit of money below 87 and
make a lot of money at 110 okay it's
like a casino ticket but guys this is
basically gabrielle is doing that with
commodity with time option traders are
doing that uh not with time but with the
strikes we take a butterfly on different
strikes so let me show you that june 17
okay bam i take three strikes and like i
said
you need to find
some strikes that are uh
around the level you're targeting so
let's say 90 110 130 all right
i
selected my strikes
don't worry you're gonna understand
everything
baba for now i had 100 so 100
okay and you buy it one time this one so
let me show you how this looks
okay so for example if you only buy so
here put zero i put zero i put zero
okay this is a call option
if you guys are a bit um aware of what
options call options are basically
giving you
a positive performance above your strike
so above here 90. so that's why this is
the piano you make
sorry guys
and as you can see above 90 the curve
starts to move higher all right
so this is the first thing we do now
we're going to cap that at 110 so if i
sell only one you can see we are capping
okay sorry
okay bam if i sell only one option now
it's a cold spread i buy here so at
night see i make money i make money
until one uh until 110. so i make 1000
dollars all right
so
and this cost me the premium of doing
that
is
bam bam bam
is one thousand us dollars which makes
sense basically because um
you're gonna spend one thousand premium
but if baba stays here uh right now baba
is at hundred
and so if you buy at
90 the first strike you're gonna make
one thousand us dollars so basically
it's a
fair uh call spread
now we make it a butterfly so we sell
two options
and we cap so if you sell two now you're
gonna lose money after 110 and then you
buy 130 all right and now
okay bam
so we have some problem
okay no sorry so only one
i'll get to put
okay bam
and here are so two
okay here i go guys so this is a
butterfly on baba 90 110 135 all right
120 so coal butterfly one by two by one
so this costs
right now 500 us dollars but if baba
stays at 110
you can make up to
uh
1 000 us dollars and if baba closes
above 130 you lose money so basically
you're betting you lose your premium so
you lose uh
500 us dollars so you're basically
making a bet that
baba is gonna trade around 110 so this
is how you use butterflies so once again
i don't want to make things too
complicated here i don't want to lose
you guys stay with me
all right
let's go back to things you enjoy
guys uh once again
i want to
do
things that you guys like right
so
let's have a look guys maybe at what is
happening
love the stream today thanks guys thank
you bro
thank you
okay so what is your take on ar
okay i don't know this stock
uh
okay i can take mulan guys because i
know that all of you are keeping
i interested in this trade
okay
so
m
m-u-l-n
milan okay so they are doing
electric vehicles guys let me just check
exactly what they do
[Music]
operates as an electric car company the
company develops electric vehicles and
energy solutions mm-hmm that's good guys
i like to see the energy world in the
description of a stock today milan
automotive serves customers worldwide
all right cool
p-e-n-a which means they're not making
money
okay short interest
one percent
one percent
hmm
i thought it was more alright fair
enough okay market cap
600 million right so it's not big guys
and whenever a market cap is not big
it's easier to move guys of course
especially if uh social medias are
starting to talk about it which is
happening on milan all right so here
guys
as usual same technique
as you can see guys
so
we are
connecting the highs all right one high
one high
okay here it's not touching and here we
have this breakout guys that happened
very quickly so we didn't really have
the consolidation consideration happened
just above okay right on it guys so here
we had this fight as usual guys whenever
you have a resistance you're gonna have
a fight around this resistance if you
don't have the fight it just means that
it was not a resistance all right simple
so here we had the fight again three
days of fight and then bulls got the
best of it okay
so
right now definitely booze and control
as you can see guys here the volume was
low guys it's a good example all right
look
three days
and look
how the volume was low so here
nobody knew what to do right
because you know it was not trading i
mean not a lot
compared to what we traded before
and then
suddenly bam massive move up guys okay
with volume increase okay so i didn't
give you this trade i was keeping an eye
on that because it seemed to me like it
can very well dump but i still can make
analysis
once again i'm trying to select the
trades that i give you guys in this code
as good as i can so that you know you
maximize i maximize the chances of
success of the trade ideas i give you
and here it was risky to me okay let's
be honest but
it's still a nice situation so let me
analyze what can happen now okay because
you guys know that i'm not hiding i
always give my view so of course
you know training is not about being
always right guys training is about
adapting uh
whenever you have information all right
so i can give you my view but even if my
view is not correct
i can adapt guys and and that's why i'm
always giving you different scenarios
different levels above which are below
which uh you might see a shift in the
trend so here i'm gonna do the same
thing guys so booze and control high
volume breakout okay
uh
we first look for the first resistance
so to find the first resistance guys you
check the past and you try to find the
consideration so here
i have definitely guys one two three
four five six seven eight nine reactions
guys that happened in deck 21
and as you can see guys even in the very
past spam guys look at that it's the
lower band of a gap up guys that
happened here it has been of course
filled so this gap this gap is not
targeted by gap fillers but we still
have a gap here it's interesting to see
that the consideration we had guys three
months ago is actually happening on the
level that traded
in june 20 guys so one and a half year
ago even more than that almost two years
all right this is the beauty of
technical analysis but whatever so
right now this level uh coming from june
20 guys is still a resistance
level so
my take okay we have one here okay let's
show you guys everything we have one
here as well
okay so my take guys is that uh so let's
see what's gonna happen here because we
have a resistance ah as well here so we
we can very well get rejected what i can
see guys is the rsi is coming to
overbought area i mean of course by now
is not a good idea all right you cannot
buy something that is already you know
moving high uh so strongly without any
consolation very close here the
consideration is 50 lower guys so it's
very hard to make a a good trade here
you can of course play you know like in
the casino just by and hope it's going
to go higher
but this is not training all right so
here
uh bam bam
like i said we arrive at a resistance at
360. next resistance is four
uh five five forty all right so if i was
in that trade which i'm not i would take
some profits right now okay i would take
maybe 30 of the profits 23 not big just
take some profits depend on when you
entered of course but take some profits
here take some profits guys at 50 not
financial advice but this is what i
would be doing and then if we manage to
go above 520
now we still have resistances all the
way up guys one at 7 20 alright so you
can also here take some i hearing a lot
of
you know questions about um mulen
that asked me if we can go fill the gap
that is here right so i mean of course
we can uh but this gap guys
is very far away
it's very far away
and
and it's going to be hard so you can
keep some of the position to take
profits here but i think that most
traders will take profits
earlier all right
first because we arrive with the rsi
that is starting to be oversold guys
over both sorry so
i mean
some traders they look at that and
they're gonna start to go against that
trade you know try to play a pullback
and
and once again guys we don't have
consideration anywhere so if you
understand the risk guys of correction
is high all right
because we there is no boot camp close
to the level we have so it would be
easier to trade if we had some
consolidation somewhere which we don't
for now
so um
so yeah this is my view guys i i don't
really know what's going to happen but i
have resistance at 360 5 7 20 and then
11 so taking maybe 10 20 at each of
these levels makes sense for those who
in this trade for those who are not in
the straight you
you can wait for a pullback and then a
consolidation okay once you have a
consolidation after a pullback you can
use this consolidation to enter all
right you buy uh whatev wherever you
want you can buy just above the
consideration just below
i mean just uh close to the bottom and
put the stop loss below this
configuration okay this is how it's
working this is how you should use
consideration so of course your
consideration can break right that's why
we use stop losses here i don't have any
consideration so i don't see any trade
idea that has a good risk reward right
guys
so that's it 95 likes 50 people watching
cool guys thank you very much for
watching
all right hit that like button let me
guys reach the 100 likes
level it's important
okay
so get one hundred one thousand five
hundred shares of million at one zero
five a nice bro okay so for you for
example if you got those one thousand
five hundred shares
uh what i've just said
can be useful for you bro all right you
can i mean not financial advice you guys
know that i'm not allowed to do that
but
it's what i would personally be doing
guys taking profits on the way up is
good buy and hold is of course good for
the long run but guys you can see that
those stocks you know
they get pumped and they get dumped all
right this is what we've seen many times
happening guys on different stocks so
don't get yourself caught in that if you
make some money guys do not hesitate to
take a little bit of profits of course
keep some for the best case scenario you
don't want to be you know you don't want
to miss the opportunity where we go very
high and you got you know out of your
trade
that's definitely not something you want
to happen but you can reduce little bit
on the way up guys that's a good
strategy that i think is very adapted
for the current environment okay let's
have a look quickly at the global market
guys let's see what is happening
and maybe we're gonna take some
positions today maybe maybe
okay
so we start to consolidate
pam pam pam
very calm
so once again guys nothing much to say
here
okay but nasdaq is going lower because
i'm making money on this deck i'm short
okay
minus 0.6 you see same situation guys on
triple q i'm having the same kind of
analysis
uh we are coming to resistance levels
and we have here another resistance
level so for those who missed the
beginning of the video
bulls and control in the short term but
we have a lot of resistances coming
close and we didn't consolidate
at all for the past five days yes so
consolidation is very much needed
hopefully it's going to happen close to
the highs right this would be the best
case scenario for bulls to push higher
but we need at least to make a pose guys
if we don't make any poses it's just
unhealthy you cannot just go higher
higher higher all right you need at some
point to have a third turnover
turn over sorry between buyers and
sellers sales in to take profits new
buyers need to get in so that we have a
sustainable rally guys right because if
you don't you don't have any taking
profits at some point they're all gonna
happen together yes so you need to see
those considerations you need to see
those small pullbacks uh the shorter
they are the smaller they are with the
lower volume that they occur the better
it is all right this is uh a good and
strong move up so here we are starting
well guys all right we just need to take
our time and yeah one once again guys i
didn't finish the sentence i made at the
beginning of that uh for those who are
asking is the is the correction over
of course i don't have the answer but i
can tell you that the vix is a key
indicator to keep an eye on guys i'm an
exception trader i used to work on the
option market guys for uh six years in a
bank and now on my own for one year so
it's been seven years guys i'm trading
options
and
i can tell you one thing is that
everybody keeps an eye on the vix okay
and it's not uh
you know random it's because the vix
is showing you how much investors are
willing to pay for protection okay this
is uh showing you what is the volatility
of the short-term uh downside options of
the s p 500 all right so basically the
one month 95 percent uh put options so
for example on spy it would be
the uh
april 420 strike this is basically
saying that the 420 strike on spy has a
volatility of 23. and uh what i want to
show you guys here is that basically
whenever vixx is above 20 as you can see
after 20 level here in green uh vixx
above 20 means danger means anything can
happen means there is tension in the
market there is fear in the market a lot
of investors are willing to pay a higher
price for protection right so this is a
very good indicator that is showing you
what the option market is pricing about
the fear of investors in the market and
a vix remember that guys a vix above 23
means anything can happen all right so
for the vix to go lower what do we need
guys we need the market to stabilize
okay so first we need time but during
this time we want uh the market not to
do you know plus two plus three minus
two all right we want the market to
become we want investors to uh you know
be posed uh we want a consolidation on
low volume with low volatility all right
guys this is what is important for
um you know
a good sign of a recovery that is gonna
come so here i have the vixx at 23 guys
so what can i say
i can only tell you that uh
that there is still fear in the market
and you can see we can do some technical
analysis on uh on the vix and you can
see that uh the 20 level is a level that
is supported supporting the price guys
right here in august 20 we were uh we
were trading uh we we found some support
at 20 here as well guys in november 20
in february and then it was resistance
and right now it is support guys in
february on uh february um 11th guys we
found support here so i can tell you
what can happen guys because right now
it's dropping all right so my guess guys
is that we go back to 20 level and we
rebound so what does it mean in terms of
the market if this happens and i think
that this is a very uh reasonable
scenario
then it means that the volatility is
dropping so if the volatility is
dropping it means that we are not moving
strongly all right in any direction so
if we're not moving strongly either we
grind
up
here
okay to 450
either we can see that below
and then
if the vix is able if we have this
consolidation with low volatility and
the vix is able to go below 20 and then
we have a breakout above 450 which is
the next resistance level for nasdaq
sorry this is sp why let's turn the sp y
then if you have a close above 450 so
let's say next week with the vx below 20
remember that guys vixx below 20 s p
above 450 this would be
uh a very good sign of the
recovery so this would mean that now the
probability that damn suddenly we drop
gas and we go to the 500 level is
decreasing can it happen of course it
can all right
but it's just lower so what i would
personally be doing if i see this
happening i would buy back my short
because as you can see
this is my portfolio guys
so making some money today it's pretty
good so once again x is moving strongly
higher and here i have some short
position as you can see bam this one
triple q
and this one s triple q okay so now the
short position is making less money amc
is making some money
gme is making some money
okay and so um
so yeah this is pretty much um
yes so i'm gonna reduce my short
position i'm always keeping some short
position and some long position but of
course as you can see i'm bullish when
the market is going higher make money
but uh sometimes i have more short
positions like i did one or two months
ago because it was looking bearish but
right now i reduced my short position
and i'm going to keep reducing it on the
way up i don't care if i don't get good
levels guys if the market is telling you
that we are bullish you need to uh you
cannot keep your short position and just
wait you know for a pullback to close it
because the pullback might never might
never happen
okay guys so i hope
i explained to you guys 99 likes come on
one more like guys and i'm at 100.
okay guys so i have breaking news guys
because right now gabriel is making a
little coffee like you know everything
is fine and he just told me guys look at
that
that this is the money he's making right
now so right now guys let me
okay he just made 40 000 u.s dollars
just on the day it's not like just now
just saying yeah on the day but the day
started i mean okay yesterday night okay
yes so in a matter of 12 hours gabriel
just did
40 000 us dollars pl guys so this is
pretty good so let's quickly have a look
at the good position so here we have the
piano guys so this is his screen once
again guys i don't want to explain
everything i'm just showing you guys
that we are here serious we're not
joking we are uh traders guys all right
so
this is crude oil okay so basically he
has a long position on crude oil uh so
like i said guys everybody's long energy
guys because you know the energy is just
going higher so once again let me give
you the chart of the crude oil guys
we're gonna quickly have a look at
gabriel's position guys i know that
uh
it might seem complicated but once again
guys you need to understand how you make
money in training all right
so this is crude oil chart
bam
okay so you have crudel chat on the left
so gabriel is along so he was long guys
for a very long time let's be honest
here he made a lot of money he closed
some positions here and he re-opened
some position here on the support level
so right now what are the winning
positions so you made 17 000 us dollars
on the long position on crude oil all
right what else do we have
well i have one which basically i have
long
silver and short gold wherever they
claim is like five but five k if you do
the sum of those two okay so he's long
silver so let's have a look guys add the
silver gabriel is long silver guys so
let's quickly have a look at the chart
of silver and then we're gonna analyze
uh because he's doing a spread guys so
basically he's buying silver selling
gold all right so silver
uh bam so i'm gonna try to find the
future
xag
manor
okay so i'm gonna use
x a g ticker
so this is a stop usd usb plug
this one
okay so we have uh xag usd guys all
right so this is chattable
uh gabriel just made seven thousand us
dollars on this today so
he is having a long position so let's
analyze the chart
all right so as you can see guys i've
never done an hc on that
so we're gonna try but guys
you can see what is happening all right
i can see it so if you are following my
videos for some time guys you know what
we're gonna do here we're gonna do as
usual a trend line guys bam
and look at that guys all right so
we are having here a trend line that is
connecting the recent highs and as you
know guys the more reactions the better
so one reaction two three four and then
look guys it's the typical situation and
gabriel didn't miss it all right we have
here first rejection first rejection
then break out gas on increasing volume
we go higher we re-test the area so uh
so right now we are at a support level
with a nice consolidation guys so uh
this is a good trade to do i totally
agree so long position until they make
sense but once again guys i remind you
that gabrielle is often doing spreads
all right so here he's not only buying
silver all right he's buying silver and
selling gold right yeah i mean the the
the worst thing is uh in the precious
markets gold has actually if you look at
gold in the same thing as you did silver
you will see that there was a breakout
much earlier than silver
probably months before
but because basically in the precious
market usually gold is always the one
starting first
and silver when silver basically ketchup
it may catch up very fast like and
actually go much higher in percentage so
the the bet i'm doing basically by being
short gold and long silver is that now
that silver has break out
it will accelerate much faster than gold
and that basically doing one versus the
other
the performance gonna be
better i mean it's it's risky but you
can do more leverage okay
you understand guys so basically he's
saying that we had a breakout on gold
we're gonna check that and right now
silver is a little bit late uh
you know after gold and silver is
usually more explosive so the rational
is that community prices are going
higher
gold has broken out already silver has
broken out already as well
and they are very correlated and they
are of course very correlated guys they
are both precious metals so right now
what we can expect is both of them going
higher but silver to go higher than gold
so here i'm having silver chad guys
all right
i see now i still do now and uh now i'm
going to show you gold chart guys
all right
so
okay
okay so i'm having gold charts gabriel
is checking if i'm using the proper
tickers because once again he's using
some futures uh because he has you know
the kind of account where you uh you can
buy futures so you need of course a lot
of money on it but guys what i'm trying
to do is to make things simple for you
and this is the reason why on discord
guys i'm using the etf just like you
because i want to put myself in your
shoes i want to take the positions that
a retail investor that doesn't have a
million dollars can take all right so we
are here uh um we got we're going to
show you guys few trades that you can
make even with small investments once
again guys not financial advice so let's
have a look at gold so as we can see
guys of course look gabriel street makes
total sense so he said that gold
breakout
occurred before
and
this is exactly what we can see guys
it's so obvious here right so look
um bam bam bam we have here so this is
gold price okay
uh i'm on the daily chart guys and you
can see i'm always using the same kind
of techniques and we have a trendline
that is here guys very clear uh wha how
many reactions you need to at least have
five reactions all right your trend line
must be visible if your training has
three reactions it's not a trend line
right it's just a line that you drew but
you need many reactions that show you
that all the trailers are using it guys
this is key remember that so here we
have one two three four
here i don't even want to count we have
seven reactions and here again and we
have those consolidations guys that are
below this trend line so
i'm you know you know purposely guys
insisting on how you do that because i
want this videos guys to be good for you
i want to teach you things and this is
important whenever you spot those
considerations be below a trend line it
makes the trend line stronger so one
consideration two consideration three
consolidations all right
we go back take some energy and then bam
break out okay guys so the breakout let
me have a look at the weekly time frame
but once again guys
this is a very interesting trade and the
the view of gabrielle here guys once
again he's a pro trader guest for the
past 10 years guys he spent all his life
making money guys for banks and now he's
making money for himself guys all right
and um and the techniques he's using are
proven techniques guys and here so he
spotted the breakout on gold that
happened before indeed guys we have this
breakout here that happened on the 15th
of feb all right guys 15th of feb then
massive rally guys and by the way
for those who are with me on discord i'm
sorry to repeat that but i really want
everybody guys to know that we shared
this alert of course guys all right
we are in the stream
this trade was given to me by gabrielle
guys okay we traded e.a.u
and as you can see
okay 15th of feb guys so this is no joke
15th of feb you can see guys this is the
uh proof that we are not just taking
some trades and say all right this could
have worked we done that we were in this
trade on the 15th of february as we gave
you the alert all right to buy a iau at
25 stop-loss 3 guys all right
so it on the 15th of feb and i can of
course guys show you uh the chart of i a
u which is the gold etf guys
and it's the exact same thing which
makes total sense of course because
it's the same uh asset behind and we
entered here guys at 25 all right
we entered here we didn't take profit
because it's a long time uh
trail but right now guys maybe i'm gonna
take profits on gold and buy some silver
and you know do gabriel straight i think
i'm gonna do this right now again all
right so we can we can do it together
because uh have a position here it's an
option position
yeah it's a bit complicated yes because
it's an option position
so um
so it's going to be a bit complicated so
we we're not going to do this right now
uh but i can open a silver position
all right so let's go back to what we
were saying
gold breakout occurred on 15th of feb
then massive move up then gold corrected
okay silver breakout
occurred
on the fourth of march three weeks two
three weeks later all right so basically
gold is a leading indicator of
the
all the met the precious metals all
right um it's like i don't know bitcoin
for the the cryptocurrency it's like snp
for uh the stock market you know you
always have some leading uh indicators i
mean the s p is not a leading indicator
it's just you know representing the
average stocks but gold here was in
advance all right this is the fact
so uh
so right now so gabriel where do you see
uh silver going okay so you guys have
silver chart so gabriel once again just
made uh seventeen thousand now seven
thousand uh usd today on um
i lost two k on gold because i have one
this is the other
okay so gold is taking 60 beeps silver
is taking one percent okay so you guys
can see the positions he's taking
because
40 difference he's making uh 5 000 us
i'm also a long one silver future so i
have this spread but on top of this i'm
also just long silver like okay
okay so he has um he has a directional
position yeah
so where do you see silver going gabriel
right now silver is trading at 25 right
this is
it it's really hard to to say because
you know there's always this thing about
the war and everything so i mean
um
my objective would be like in the thirty
dollars but it doesn't mean that i'm not
gonna cut my position before
like probably if we go to 28 i would
probably
uh sell my position and then try to buy
it back at 20 27 26
and then if i miss
the
like uh you know the thing from 28 to 30
i mean that's fine i would actually have
made money already uh but i'm not trying
to basically
target uh something where it's just
going to to the moon directly i'm i'm
more trying to to do this variation and
another trade i actually on silver is i
have options so the option i'm gonna
keep it no matter what
and then on the futures where you know
let's say tomorrow i don't know just
making apocalypse trade where it goes 50
down in one day
if i had the future position and if i
had no stop i would lose a lot of money
uh so this is one of the when i do
futures and commodities i like to take
profit there and there that's why he's
using options you understand guys if you
want to be build the big positions uh
using options you have a stop loss uh
you know inside your position kind of
because uh you cannot lose more than
what you invest whenever you use futures
you're gonna have margin calls guys on
the way down and you need to be prepared
for that because if you don't put your
own stop loss you can get stopped by the
exchange if you don't have enough funds
right so remember that guys if you want
to take big positions don't go to
futures if you're not um you know
eat um
used to trade those instruments so let's
go back to the question so where do you
think uh silver can go gabriel you said
you have uh so you can see guys here we
have a resistance he said 28 30. and
guys i'm not surprised uh here i have
definitely a resistance at 28 which is
the first recent high guys so i think
that i have the same target as gabriel
yes 28 i think is the level we can reach
so we're talking here about uh bam bam
bam
15 guys so silver going to 28 is a level
that makes sense but once again you
heard what he said uh he's gonna take
some profits on the way up guys even
when you have a target uh you can uh you
know just
um
secure some gains whenever the price is
going higher
but the thing about silver is basically
if really he explodes on the way up
it can go very very quick so if you look
just after the covet so if you go back a
bit on your graph you will see that
during the covet crisis we were 12 okay
so coffee crisis guys okay
we were at 12
just before
the commit crisis around here we're
right at 14 i see
but
i mean i'm just just here this is this
is down here like you have here yeah
okay so just after the communication
yeah so silver
silver was turning at 12. all right we
get that after basically we had this
massive rally where we went from 12 to
30. so it's kind of not three x per
you know two and a half
uh and then you have another case i
think he was in 2008 uh just after the
is it
i can't remember but there's another
thing where we went up to no it's not
sunday it's not before than that but we
went like 25 50 or something so
the thing about silver is a very
explosive market
and then if really you know people want
it it can basically go high very very
quick okay it was it was uh just after
so here at
i took a weekly chat guys on the silver
because we are having some nice breakout
guys so let's analyze the past as usual
and try to see guys uh what information
you can get from the past so here as you
can see yes silver since 203 weekly
chart uh and you can see guys that after
indeed the 208 crisis we had a massive
okay rebound a little bit like the coin
but guys the move we had here in 2020 is
absolutely massive and right now guys we
have this long-term kind of
consolidation guys that is here and guys
does it remind you something look at
that guys all right look at that april
22 uh 2010 guys 2010 uh we had the same
kind of phenomenon guys a crisis a
massive move up a consolidation that
lasts all right let's see how long guys
november 209 july 2010 one year of
correction right now guys we're on a
correction since august 20 till
uh jan 22 yes one and a half years so
it's very similar look what happened
afterwards guys bam okay so this is no
joke guys indeed when silver starts to
be bullish guys we are talking here
about 150
move up guys this is really uh some
massive moves so let's be you know let's
try to see if this is happening again
yeah so for now i wouldn't say we have
this breakout okay for this breakout to
be validated guys we would need to close
above 28. so keep that in mind guys if
we go to 28 maybe taking some um profits
if your long silver is adapted by the
way the silver trade guys is good to go
now not financial advice again but we
are just above the breakout level i'm
gonna buy some silver right now very
soon guys
but 28 is the first level to take
profits and then guys let's just be
crazy and imagine we have the same move
up
that we had uh after to eight so this
would bring us guys to the 55 level
let's check if this level is also a
level that we had before and yeah guys
so you see this is the situation if we
break out above 28 we might very well go
quickly to 50 guys and this is the kind
of trade that you might want to be in
so um anything you wanted to say gabriel
about
no i mean the thing
i think uh the precious market right now
is there's a lot of people buying it
which is i mean it could be either gold
or silver mainly you will
gold because this is the main one
uh because of you know the war in
ukraine um people basically like
especially central bank
will try to basically have a set in gold
and if you look at the gold etf so if
you go if you have bloomberg on this on
this computer you can look at the ticker
i can lose this one no no i want to show
you something else so if you go on
bloomberg okay so we're gonna go on
bloomberg guys so bloomberg is the
professional
uh
tool that we use that we have always
used when we work in banks guys and so
gabriel wants to show me something here
on the gold etf guys so let's have a
look at that
once again guys this guy knows what what
he's doing guys he's just made 40 000 us
dollars right now guys alright so this
is the reason why i came here as well
guys because i want to learn you know
from him of course guys it's very good
to work in a team because we have
different methods all of us guys and i'm
here to learn everything guys he can
teach me so he's going to teach you
stuff as well i'm going to make it easy
for you to understand so right now we're
looking at a spread between gold and
silver no this is not this this one is
not spread no no i know but we were
looking at this thread and so you wanted
to show us something on the gold etf so
what is it so this is this graph
basically is showing you if you look at
all the gold etf out there
how many go how many ounces of gold
are held by those etf because what you
need to know is when someone buy a gold
etf somewhere in the world there will be
some gold stored in a vault that is
representing uh this value you bought uh
from the atf so for example tomorrow i
buy one million watts of gold etf it
means that somewhere in a vault actually
there is one million worth of gold for
me okay so you understand yes this is
basically showing uh the inventory
somehow yeah inventory of quality this
is the inventory of the gold in the etf
so let's have a look at how we analyze
this information so you can see guys
that this is going higher than lower so
i see it's pretty much correlated to
gold right so yeah of course because
this is flows so if this is this is if
you basically have a lot of people
buying of course they will push gold
higher but what i'm saying is uh from
you
but basically from the time uh
this crisis started and even before you
start seeing the flow in this gold etf
because it is skyrocketing it started
basically kind of from january onwards
and you see that the eclipse is curved
it's basically starting going so so what
does it mean what does it mean we can
see here so guys i saw the situation
we're looking at the gold market we've
seen that the gold uh price is giving us
a nice breakout and now gabriel is
telling me let's have a look at the
inventory of gold that is stored in a
fault whenever someone is buying the
gold etf so how can we use this
information well it's more like an
indicator telling you that uh gold etf
investors are buying and they're buying
strong okay because you can see that
basically it's it's very kind of it's
very steep we've been we've been in that
period for basically a year
where where it's been kind of drifting
down but now basically we're starting
back that thing where we're going very
strong so this is a good signal for you
that the gold
price is going to keep going higher it's
basically a good thing that right now a
lot of investors are buying gold right
and now of course i don't know what the
future will be but if if you were seeing
gold going higher and this is going
lower
i would not think that the movement in
gold would be able to continue
because right now
you see the flow in gold and you see and
you have gold going higher i think
basically we are in a trend where it's
gonna dry it doesn't mean that we may
not see minus two minus three percent
tomorrow yeah of course of course but
it's just and gold is a long term scene
you need to look at it on a monthly or
weekly thing you understand guys uh so
basically some of the situation we have
some breakouts on gold we have some
breakouts on silver we've checked that
in the past silver can make a massive
massive move up all right
so we are bullish on silver but of
course it's correlated to gold so we
want to see if the breakout on gold is
good and reliable and we have another
information that is coming from what
gabriel just told us guys which is uh
the gold etf storage right once again
guys don't really uh okay it's important
to understand what you are looking at
but um just keep in mind guys that it's
an indicator of how many uh physical
gold people actually buying and we can
see that this curve guys that i've just
shown you is getting steep guys this is
gabriel's analysis once again he's been
trading commodities for the past 10
years guys and he's telling us that this
is confirming uh so i don't have the
trend line here okay here
okay we can even see a breakout here but
whatever it's not the purpose we're not
here to make tea on this we're here to
see the steepness guys of this curve
which is showing that people buy gold
but guys i'm not surprised look at the
situation in the world look at what is
happening in ukraine yes there are
tensions everywhere we don't know what
china is going to do we don't know
what's going to happen people are
talking about the third world war guys
nuclear war i don't know i don't think
this can happen let's be honest but
people are scared and i understand that
um as a european citizen guys i'm scared
as well we don't know what is happening
guys in uh you know in our continent so
you know buying gold is something that
makes sense when you're scared right you
you know the equity market is already
high
uh the rates are still very low guys so
what can you do with your money guys you
you go to gold so um and when you have
inflation as well because you it's kind
of basically you want to protect your
money and right now the thing is you
know if in the world which currency do
you want to hold that you know it's
going to keep your your your value so if
you are in a russian you definitely
don't want to have rubble because you're
going to be like you know with a
resistor so you think russians are
buying gold actually i mean
some russian central bank is buying gold
yes but now i mean the russians itself i
don't know what they're doing is i can't
tell you right but i'm just saying
in a case where you don't really trust
your currency and you want to have
something that you know
you should appreciate then you would buy
gold because
it's not it's not a money you can create
like there is only a certain amount of
gold you can you can
mine every year it's not like a dollar
where uh over the last year i think 80
percent of the running supply of dollar
has been printed so i i can't remember
the number but i think something like
there was there used to be maybe five
trillion worth of dollar in circulation
after 2020 or something and now there is
like 20 in circulation because just
because of this crisis so much has been
printed so
in theory uh your
your dollar
is worth less it was less than where it
used to be right and this is why you
understand yes there is inflation
created by the printing all right the
fed is printing money printing money
printing money so of course the
evaluation of the currency is inevitable
all right and so this is creating
inflation and in a period of inflation
especially inflation and tension uh you
want to place your money in something
that is protecting it right so buying
gold makes sense once again we're here
analyzing the fundamentals around this
asset and guys it's just you know
everything is for now pointing towards
the same direction is that investors buy
gold and uh the technicals are bullish
guys so you get reality
but you basically have this whole thing
about bitcoin because you can't trade
bitcoin right but now it's true that i
mean it's bitcoin as you're seeing last
year
now it's kind of uh trading in the water
you don't know where it's gonna go
and so right now i prefer like you know
i prefer to have a bit of bitcoin and so
a bit of gold rather than bitcoin but it
doesn't mean that bitcoin will not come
back i'm just saying that from a
technical perspective technical
indicator right now i'm more bullish on
gold
than i am on uh on bitcoin now
you know we'll see what happens in the
coming weeks say bitcoin could go above
50k or something which i think is a key
level
and if we there maybe i will add the
more bitcoin but uh right now i'm more
like on on the gold trend than on the
bitcoin okay guys so we've made a big
analysis of the community market now
let's take some positions guys so we're
gonna take a position at silver you guys
know that i'm an option trader and
options are good to buy especially guys
in this area so we're gonna take an
option trade together guys let's build
this together so
like i said
look at the chart this is silver chart
this is x xag usd guys breakout retest
so i should have bought yesterday yes
i'm a bit late but it only took one
person yes it's a
medium term position so i'm gonna take
here i'm gonna go to the june option
market but remember something if you buy
call options
just after a breakout you're gonna pay a
lot you're gonna because the volatility
is high if you buy a call option on a
retest like right now guys and
especially consideration the volatility
has dropped okay so
uh what we're going to do guys is that
we're going to have a look at the
options that we can do on silver so uh
am i gonna use xag usd what what what
other
etf can i use for silver
slv
slv yeah slv
we uh you guys maybe remember we did
some slv trading discord recently
uh so we can use that as an etf okay so
we're gonna take options on slv okay so
let's price the options okay here i'm on
my option spreadsheet guys
bam slv
so i'm going to share this trade idea in
discord as well guys so for those who
are with me in this code uh you're going
to receive the trade idea together and
i'm sorry guys once again please don't
be pissed if i'm sharing some of the
content that i'm sharing with you with
everyone but i think it's uh you know
it's very fair that i i share some of
this content even with non-paid member
guys um all right and if you are really
pissed just let me know guys but i hope
that you enjoy that alright so we're
gonna try to do some slv options
okay so maturity
okay so we're gonna go to june so what
are we targeting guys we're targeting
maybe a crazy move okay and we're also
targeting
so we said uh
28 which was the recent high so on slv
this recent high is slightly lower guys
there is a spread between xag usd and
slv of around two points remember it was
at 25 here is 23 so we would say 26
okay so this is what we target
so what we're gonna do guys is that
we're gonna try to take a strike that is
at the level we target and we're gonna
take some profits if we arrive on it and
if we cross it we're gonna let it run
okay so i don't know if i go to june
options or gen 23 options guys so i'm
gonna check right now with you guys the
liquidity so i'm taking my interactive
broker account guys bam
i type slv
bam
okay and we're gonna look for options
guys all right
so i'm going to the option chain
bam and i want to see what is the
liquidity so first i'm going to check
the dune liquidity and we're targeting
strikes between all right
26
and 30 maybe so let's add some strikes
guys
bam so 28 strike we added 30 strike we
added and 26 strikes we added all right
so first that what's the price so you
can see
it's very tight guys we have a bit offer
in one cent okay so it's extremely tight
so that's good now let's cheat let's
check the liquidity
on
uh
on the gen 23 guys maturity because this
is a long-term trade guys pam it's very
tight guys so it's perfect you see this
is a good market so we're going to go to
gen 23 options because we have a
long-term view
and we are going to buy some 28
uh strikes
of this maturity y28 once again guys
because
it's good to take a strike that is not
too far so 28 let me show you guys
here
uh so gen 23 so let me check change this
uh here
maturity 28 guys so this is the kind of
piano that we can expect guys this is my
option spreadsheet some of you know it
already
okay basically what you only need to
know is that here i can build my
strategies guys
okay so i have a price of 170 okay and
this is the piano i can make all right
so i can lose 170 and if uh so let me
zoom in here a little bit
maximum let's say
okay
16. we said that okay in the best case
scenario we can go to uh 55 all right
remember that guys
55 would be a very nice target 50. so
that's why taking a 30 strike guys it's
perfect if you want to uh
maximize your profits
uh
at this level so let's check here how
much money we can make and we're gonna
then decide what kind of position we
take okay so here you have the chart of
the pnm guys all right so this is the
payoff you have at maturity if you go
for 28 uh strike maturity gen 23
okay so we buy it right now at 170 us
dollars right and if uh silver is going
to 50 so the best case scenario i know
guys but just to show you we make 2000
us dollars right so minus the 170 that
we invested we make 180
100
1830 us dollars which is a very nice
piano now if silver only goes to 30
we're not gonna so we need to be quick
guys okay because the time is playing
against us we pay some theta guys we pay
one usd every day to hold this position
okay this is the theta i'm having this
column
uh so if silver gets to 28
oh no sorry this is already
yeah this is already the piano we make
this is not the present value okay this
is the piano so if so here we make two
thousand us dollars profits and here if
you go to 28 we can make 200 us dollars
profit so we can uh double our
investment if it happens in the next two
uh two two months okay
so
so it's a very good trade guys we're
gonna go for that so now the question is
how much do we invest
uh so
as you know guys uh i'm trying to make
trades that are at the size of
uh
of a portfolio of ten thousand us
dollars so let's imagine here i'm
managing
let's say twenty thousand adoption uh
portfolio is twenty thousand us dollars
so uh i think we can invest
at least 500 okay
at least 500 us dollars in that so if
you want to invest more not financial
advice but you need to do only one i'm
personally gonna buy three
uh jan 23 28 calls all right guys so i'm
gonna do this right now
first let me share the alerts
in this code guys okay
so i'm showing the others live guys
so silver is breaking out
above
uh 23 so slv is above 23 let me double
check that
okay so the breakout area is 22.5
and you see we don't have exactly the
same trend lines that's why it's good to
have a look at different
uh
assets representing the same thing here
the trend line is better like that
because the retest area is at 22 so the
breakout occurred
at 22 23 all right
above 22 23.
okay and it is now retesting
the breakout area okay so let's check
guys we are here to make you know proper
things so you guys know that i like to
see the volume increase during breakout
so i don't know if we see it on slv
because slv is an etf but let's have a
look we saw it on silver so the trade is
legit anyways
okay so the volume increase
okay we have this bad day here
with a red day on the on a higher volume
but then we had a volume increase that
was massive guys during the breakout and
the next move up so the volume dynamics
is not perfect let's be honest but it's
good enough and then the retest is
happening on low volume so it's good as
well so what i'm gonna do i'm gonna be a
buyer right now and if it goes lower i'm
gonna buy more that's why i put only 500
us dollars so that i keep some cash if i
want to increase my position on the way
down okay guys
so bam bam bam
uh
all right so i was writing on this code
seeing the breakout area
okay
so next resistance is what
next resistance is 26
[Music]
okay so tread idea
so slv is breaking out above 23 22 23
on the weekly time frame
okay so that's why we take a term trade
trade idea
so buy it
so i put three but you know this is for
500 us dollars premium by three
jan
23
twenty
eight cores
okay
it's 28 right
it's this one at 170
okay i'm gonna do the trade after i send
to the alert guys as usual you first me
after
them by three time
okay so total
premium
equal
so at
170
so total premium 510 usd right if i'm
not wrong three times seven two hundred
and ten it's good
okay guys and as usual i'm gonna give
you a chart them
okay this is not working up i need to
adapt to my new working environment so
we have the sleeping tool pump
okay
i send all that so you guys in discord
just received the alert okay
so now i'm gonna take my position so 170
guys
okay bam so i select this one
we said we buy three
limits you see we have a bit offering
four
we're gonna press place it at 170 guys
you know i don't like to lift the offer
oh it's not accepted
okay i have some margin issues i need to
reduce some positions
okay i'm gonna buy like that
okay i just need to reduce some position
guys so i had some short call positions
on gme when we started to move down now
we are back above 87
so i can reduce a little bit and i made
money on that already i like to buy
shazam to say calls like i told you
guys okay
so you guys have some
internet issues
stay with me guys give me some likes
bam bam bam okay
okay
wait a sec
i need to be executed on this one
okay give me a sec guys i need to clean
up some positions
okay i'm done i reduce the position so
now i can go back to the silver trade
bam bam bam here we go
okay because i was consuming too much
margin with my short coil position all
right
so now the price is a little bit higher
okay let's
let's try to target the mid 172 guys we
buy three options
here
bam
okay guys done so first live trend with
you guys i told you that we will take
positions
so here we go and as usual guys let me
send that in the chat
okay so i
bought a little bit higher at 172
okay so trades
okay
done at 172.
okay
so that's cool guys we're bullish on
silver
all right let me quickly have a look
are your questions guys
okay
so here we go
mullen is on fire indeed guys
so nasdaq snp
i just did that
are silver and gold the same what do you
mean nota
you can you cannot do future as you're
saying but i just told i just showed you
a trade on slv which is not a future slv
is a stock is an etf that is tracking
the silver price right so i've just done
a trade on that guys once again i'm
doing trades that you can do as well
right
so
what else do we have
this is too much for my small brain no
bro don't worry
things might seem complicated but
sometimes they're not that complicated
okay
okay so i have a question on emc
uh if we hit hundred thousand dollars
for example okay
how's that going going to in fact to
affect the economy so what's going to
happen okay so you're talking about
hundred and thousand uh level right so
it's a crazy level um but
if
a massive massive short squeeze
uh happen
then
what's gonna happen
is that we're gonna have some events
that never happened before right some
unprecedented
unprecedented events sorry
uh and
um
and no one knows what can happen but i
can tell you one thing
is that
uh
basically regulators are gonna probably
uh intervene they're gonna create some
halts okay so they're gonna stop some
trading days but
uh
they cannot stop trading
so
uh if they are buyers that absolutely
need to buy
and there are no sellers
then
uh then we can reach some crazy levels
but it's not gonna last all right so how
it's gonna impact so it's maybe we can
go so hundred thousand years i've never
talked about i've never um
yeah talked about such a big level
i don't think it's like really something
that can happen but 1000 is possible it
would be a very very quick event that's
going to happen very quickly guys and in
a matter of a few minutes a few you know
maybe 10 minutes uh the price is gonna
drop they're gonna basically probably um
prevent people from buying so they're
gonna be only sellers in the market
they're gonna do this on purpose for the
price to come back so you need to be
very very quick so what i advise you
guys to do once again not financial
advice but a little bit but
um is to place orders before whenever
things start to get hot they're not hot
now we have time guys and i'm gonna be
here to update you whenever things start
to do good um what you need to do is to
place orders
before the squeeze happens because
whenever the squeeze is going to happen
you're not going to be able to access
your broker you're not going to be able
to trade amc okay keep that in mind
they're going to stop uh you know
they're gonna try to make things calm so
um
so if you have your orders placed before
they are already in the market and if
they're buyers that absolutely need to
buy whatever the price you know this is
how hedge funds uh work you know that
whenever there is a loss to take and the
other signal from management to take the
loss they take the loss right and they
buy whatever the price so if you have
your orders placed before the squeeze
okay squeeze let's say we can consider
something squeezing whenever we have a
move of more than fifty hundred percent
you know uh a few days in a row okay
this is a squeeze so then if you're the
place you can get executed and um and
lock in some profits and if you don't do
that before guys the price is going to
jump and come back so to answer the
question
if we hit hundred and thousand us
dollars right hundred thousand is
totally crazy but let's say we hit that
so what's going to happen is that a very
low volume is going to trade extremely
low volume there's not going to be a lot
of shares exchanged at that level and um
and you want of course to be in the
shells that's what you need to place
your orders before in gtc orders
uh and some hedge funds are probably
gonna uh follow but that's it guys
nothing more is gonna happen all right
because there's not gonna be a lot of
volume so it's not gonna be a transfer i
mean
if it happens gradually there can be a
massive transfer of wealth but
most likely it's gonna be very quick
and
only some hedges so maybe a few billion
dollars are going to go which is already
a lot guys right
from um
hedge funds to retail investors if
retail have placed the orders before um
and then it's going to come back right
this is what's going to happen so
i think so um
so so it's not going to impact really
the global economy if you want to give
an example with weapon with sneaker just
as a crazy scenario yeah yeah true true
uh we can have a look at that guys this
is a good example for example uh bam
so
we have some crazy things guys happening
right now so you can i'm not sure i can
find it here yes nickel futures
i think it's good okay
i mean basically i'm just gonna make it
quick because maybe it's not something
you know interest all your thing but
basically on nickel
uh like we know with this crisis in uh
in ukraine
uh
and russia and russia is the main
producer of nikkei so there was a lot of
uh
worries that there would not be enough
naked out there okay so
nickel gas is a commodity is a metal so
here you have the chart of nickel and uh
and
listen to the story guys all right so
nickel went super high as you can see
here guys we went from
300 percent okay 300 yes this was uh
last week guys alright so this is
something hot and listen to that guys
because it's relevant for what can
happen with amc you're gonna see what
the regulator did here guys it's not the
regulator it's the exchange guys so
listen to the story luke just are giving
you some context we were training on
march 7th at 2000 on march
so so i mean this is not exactly uh
how would look at the nickel price but
the graph is more or less accurate so
it was about 300 percent
there was some people that were
massively short massively short on
nickel
and the thing like who you could say
like amc some people were massively
short and because of uh you know the war
everyone starts rushing to basically buy
nickel
and uh like it properly the price kind
of three times higher
and on one day i can't remember which
day but basically is a price so that's
why i don't like to look at this price
the price went up to hundred thousand
dollars
uh for for nico
and he was going to put bankrupt like a
lot of people okay so
okay gabriel likes to look at the real
threadable
assets so i'm having bloomberg guys once
again bloomberg is for professionals
that's why i'm always showing you
something on trading view so that you
can compare but here we need to look at
the real nickel presser once again niko
is a metal is a precious metal and we
had a short squeeze here guys last week
okay a massive short squeeze there were
a lot of shock positions look at that
guys so can you put big screen
all right so you have in here the nikkel
uh futures
uh
yeah so basically it's more or less the
nickel features but why is basically on
this on this day the 7th of march you
can already see how crazy you went
but what you don't see so here just to
show you you see here is the 7th of
march and look after what date is this
this is the 16th of march okay so guys
the exchange closed okay after the short
squeeze the exchange uh the cme
lme exchange so this is real yes you can
find news about that they stopped
trading for one week after the short
squeeze happened and listen yes that's
not only what happened there's some
crazy some shady things happen here guys
it's really bad but it's a reality and
it's i think relevant to what can happen
with amc so yeah tell us more so
basically what you don't see here is
that on the 8th of march there was
actually actually a trading session
that where where you see when nickel
went up to 100 000 okay you see a
hundred thousand guests even double than
that so
i i sum up what have just been said on
this on the eighth
seventh of march we take uh
three hundred percent okay in one day we
go from three thousand to thirty
thousand from
thirty thousand to fifty five thousand
so we take a little bit less than
hundred percent the next day we had a
training session guys okay
that started around fifty thousand
probably and went to hundred thousand
but guys you cannot see it here and
this is the reason why you can't see it
so basically because this trade here as
i was going up 200 thousand was making
like the market was only unliquid and it
was not functioning anymore like
basically you could say probably i
don't know
but basically it went here
and it was putting so many people in
bankrupt that the exchange decided to
erase the session so imagine you were
buying nickel at 50 000 on the previous
day and on that day you managed to sell
your nickel at 100 000
well the exchange actually said we're
gonna cancel this day
and so that it doesn't exist
because the trade make no sense
so you could have basically make so much
money on the day on the eighth of march
it doesn't matter because election will
have say no guys we this session doesn't
exist we're gonna erase it
and then basically uh after that
everyone was so pissed off
because you know you they were uh
like basically losing money that they
were made
and they basically took a week
to to find a solution and since then
basically the price is just going down
and down and down
and
it basically proved that you could have
been in a kind of correct position
but could not get out
and that basically now even if you want
to get out you can't even get out
because
the every day that the exchange open
because of the new rules that it cannot
go down more than a certain percentage
and no one wants to buy this price so
even if you want to sell you can't sell
so someone that could have made money on
that day that was cancelled now is
actually on the loss
okay guys so i found here an article
okay i just typed uh nikhil
lme cancel and i found this article so
lme forced to halt nikhil trading cancel
deals after prices top hundred and
thousand right so this is what we've
we've been just telling you guys the
price went to fifty thousand plus
hundred percent then it went two hundred
and thousand the next days the next day
and there were so many uh counterparties
guys that were going to be bankrupt
right short sellers that were going to
just close uh completely the company um
that
the lme which is the exchange had no
other choice to save the economy and not
save the economy but i mean to protect
those big
clients that could trigger a system a
systemic risk they had no other choice
than canceling the trading day i guess
do you realize it was training so you
could have been a buyer or a seller of
nickel
and the next day they're just gonna come
to you and tell you oh sorry uh actually
the trade you have done yesterday and
that made you make big money is not uh
gonna be uh
valid exactly so they cancelled it guys
so this is crazy this is pure market
manipulation guys and this just happened
last week on mikkel uh so this is
showing you guys what's happened during
a short quiz uh
unfortunately the big
investors the big clients are protected
why it's not only because they pay it's
because if they fall it can trigger some
bad things for the rest of the economy
and the exchange will do whatever they
can to prevent that from happening even
if they have to um you know
to scam the smaller investors because
this is a scam yes there is no other
word they people who sold nikkeil at a
hundred thousand
uh so around here guys on my chart
uh
you know
they they got scammed guys they did the
winning trade uh you know so for example
on amc we can consider the same thing if
amc goes to i don't know one thousand
and you you sell there
because you you take profit and there
are some hedge funds that were short
because we know they are short
and they buy back to you so they buy
your share at one thousand then it's
still possible that the exchange comes
to you and say sorry we invalidate this
trade all right so keep that in mind
guys we are not in a fair way i would
say is less probable on a stock though
than on a commodities market like nickel
right no because basically nickel is
kind of have an impact on the economy so
imagine if you know uh all your like
tomorrow i don't know you're not going
to buy nickel in the shop but you know
everything is going higher 4x 5x the
price right it's going to have an impact
on everyone so only on everyone's
portfolio right so versus amc or gm is
just just just a single stock
i don't know okay okay i think the
effect is kind of different like and
then that's where the nickel market okay
i would think the nickel market is
bigger than the wall
here uh
so let's check it out let's check let's
check so you you you hear that guys so
gabriel is just telling us that for him
what happened on nickel is unlikely to
happen on amc and the reason behind is
that there are much uh
much many more um
investors
um in yeah involved in the trade in the
nickel thread than in the amc trade so
let's check that we guys uh we know what
is the volume trading amc every day
right so let's check that
so amc
us equity
i don't think the volume is gonna really
represent it because
okay so you wanna adjust so much volume
from retail that
it may be kind of inflated you know this
is a volume
maybe you can do the difference i
actually don't know what's gonna
lead to i just think that
may not give you the exact reply you
want to see
okay so we have roughly 20 million
shells training an amc every day so the
market cap is 20 billion and we have
roughly uh 20 million shares and uh
so 20 million so roughly two three
billion to three billion us dollars
trading every day which is representing
roughly ten percent of the total market
cap now
if we want to find uh how many shares
what is the volume trading on nikkiel
every day how can we do that um
let me give you a minute
we're gonna come back to you guys with
this information we are checking that
for you we are trying to know if the
short squeeze that happened on nickel
can be handled the same way on amc or
not guess because i think it's an
interesting question
okay guys okay okay so what you do is
you're in bloomberg or just so it's on
your side okay okay so gabriel is
telling me what to do guys so
i'm gonna try to find the information so
what should i type ln
one
commodity
city
okay so you guys i'm using blueberry
once again this is a professional tool
we can find a lot of information here
okay now so what am i looking at
you want to change the day before the
squeeze so uh let's put it just one way
one month ago just
to be before anything okay
and what you have
here is all the the futures contract of
nickel and here is the daily volume
so what you would have to do to kind of
find how many
notional has been traded is some all of
those volume
so basically say 15 25 35 well let's
call it 50 000 overall okay so this you
are 50 on the future times 50 thousand
times the price okay so you see yes of
the future okay
so basically fifty thousand to the
square guys
uh uh
is it fifty thousand the price
because you need to look at fifty seven
the future price by the price at the
time
at the time it was not fifty thousand
dollars it was how much
okay so what i would do
is
is this so how many contracts so first
you need to look at
basically
the contract size so the contract value
for a price of 37 000 is basically 200k
okay so it's much higher so if you put
yourself yeah yeah yeah okay so double
that right okay if you put yourself back
in history
in history let's say one month ago
you were at twenty four thousand dollar
so let's call it um let's let's put it
okay it's roughly it's roughly two
hundred uh okay so it would be hundred
forty four thousand okay a contract so
you need to be doing yeah yeah so it's
three times more than what i did it's
150k okay so we are talking here about
roughly 7 billion us dollars that were
exchanged at that price so let's be
honest guys it's not more than amc amc
is trending 2 billion in a normal day so
in a squeeze day guys amc can trade 20
million in one day so um amc is big guys
and it's big enough to create
uh like we say guys there can be blood
on the wall you know uh if amc squeezes
so and we can see what happens when
there is blood on the wall they protect
the big money players because they want
them to survive to avoid any systemic
risk any uh you know more troubles that
can be created to the economy
so guys we are not in a fair environment
all right retail investors are always
going to get uh the ones that are going
to be sacrificed for uh the greater good
like they say right so just be prepared
for that know where you are
and
like like i said guys hundred thousand
is to me
too high guys it's not the target i i i
want to really talk about i don't think
they will let this happen right they
will do something before guys 135 is my
target and this level can be reached
and if we go there there might be some
shady things happening from the exchange
but they might as well leave the trade
like they are all right if they have no
other choice if there is you know
pressure from uh people that don't want
um you know let this happen
then the trades may be uh just confirmed
so i'm repeating what i said guys
whenever things are gonna start to get
hot start to place your orders guys all
right because we might go to the moon
but we're not going to stay there i
think if i may add one thing as well uh
is uh you know lme is under uh kind of
uh british law okay versus gm emc's
under usa ah that's important so maybe
you know in the us you can't do what
they did in in element okay right so you
see guys we just give you information
like they are uh we don't know of course
what can happen we are just checking
what happened before on the other market
so here we take and we took an example
of nickel and on the lme exchange which
is um referring to the british law and
as you guys know the us financial laws
are different so maybe they're not gonna
let this happen hopefully all right let
me have a look quickly guys if you have
questions
and it's been almost three hours guys
i'm here 125 likes guys thank you so
much
click that like button again guys i mean
not again but for those who didn't like
guys smash that like button guys do it
for the channel it's been three hours we
are live here we took some uh trade on
silver
uh i wanted as well guys to take some
positions on
um
on snp futures spy
okay but it's gonna be a bit complicated
okay
so what happens to the stock if they
cancel but look at what happened to
nickel
it's dropping right when when it's
cancelled so it's not going to happen
but people who bought here
i mean
they still need to sell right
and that's why we are just dropping
heavily guys right we are dropping
heavily on nickel
because there was a short squeeze with
some cancellation of orders
and um
and people still need to sell all right
those who bought here they need to sell
and short sellers they're going to keep
their shop position they're not buying
anymore all right because they know
they're protected so this is what is
happening all right this is it just
dropping all right so be prepared for
that
okay i did mulen already i can do it
again okay i can finish this life guys
by coming back to the basics so i'm
seeing questions about
uh
are you bricked yes bro i'm bricked of
course bro i'm very happy to be here and
very happy to be with you guys okay
i hope you enjoyed this guys we're gonna
do that every day
okay
okay so do i get my share back uh
shari's is asking
you you you don't really get your shares
back i mean
you cannot sell so yeah you keep your
shares you keep your shares if there is
a squeeze and they cancel treads you
sold but they give you the chest at the
price it's worse ran right now so
basically you got scammed all right this
is what happens
okay so bam bam bam
milan amc guys i'm gonna quickly come
back to that and once again guys let me
know if you want to see me doing day
trading on amc or not i don't know if
it's something that can be annoying for
you or if it's interesting uh i
personally prefer to let amc where it is
guys this is a stuff that i don't know
if day trading is really good on that
kind of stock guys i prefer to day trade
spy
i prefer to um
i prefer to day trade
you know other stocks but if you really
want to see me day trading amc i can do
that for you guys so just let me know in
the comments let me know in the chat
okay so milan we checked that this
morning
let's have another look
woohoo
guys
okay
so
it's very strong guys
the volume is already here and the day
has not passed yet
we're about to close about four so it's
the same thing that i said guys all
right
we are moving higher but we didn't
consider that at all so the dump might
happen as quick as the pump okay keep
that in mind
so it's very hard guys to predict where
it's gonna go okay let's be honest i can
only give you some resistance areas all
right and there was a resistance at four
at sorry
yeah four roughly 360. it just got
destroyed so we didn't close above yet
so maybe the price action is going to
come back before the close i don't know
but basically we have resistance level
at 360. so this one is crushed already
next one is five 720 right so taking a
little bit of profits on the way up is i
think a smart move
okay
let's check amc quickly
i saw it's moving nicely
okay
plus two percent again nothing crazy
guys
but
okay what can i say guys i already done
uh i've already done an analysis on in
here uh we still have decreasing volume
so we want to see the volume coming back
guys we want to see a consolidation
happening somewhere so that um we know
what is the level to take back now it's
unclear to me what level will really
trigger the strong moves that we're
waiting for uh i think we need time guys
i'm saying that for quite some time but
for now i'm right unfortunately um i
would prefer to be wrong on this one and
to see a massive screws happening but
for now what's gonna happen is that
we're probably gonna oscillate we're
moving sideways guys moving sideways
after brutal move down like that is
bullish it's the beginning of a reversal
but for reversal to be sustainable guys
we need to close above some important
level like 18 21 all right so this is
what we want to see i see uh the next
resistance at 18 so we might see a small
rejection here
um
okay i'm pretty much neutral guys
between 14.5
and 18 21 and here guys is the really
the area that we need
to go above after consolidation so maybe
in april may guys so i think we have
time the option market is not rebuilt
yet
uh this is something that is important
guys for squeeze
to happen like i said before
all right
okay and gme
i know the gym so jamie fundamentals are
very different from amc i totally agree
with that guys they have different
business models
for now those two stocks are moving
together uh because you know they're
representing the meme movement okay
let's be honest and this is the reason
why there is such a high correct
correlation between those two stacks
some say that there is some manipulation
around it that keeps them moving
together i don't know it's possible as
well guys
what i know is that for now technicals
are showing roughly the same signals i
don't think that one can fly without the
other all right if we see jimmy flying
amc will fly uh the other way around is
true as well guys
so um
so yeah i can do gme of course again
i've done it at the open
whoa plus nine percent
so indeed guys is it today yes nice
nice move up
so let's go now little friend
okay so it's just moving higher guys
so like i said jme is getting back to
the hundred level guys so the 105 i said
because we have the 20-day moving
average so we are moving nicely higher
guys
we have some uh some strong volume so
the jamming chat is more bullish than
amc chart okay i don't want to make any
opposition between those two stocks like
i said i think they move together but
you just need to um to see the facts
guys the fact is that gme volume traded
on friday guys was absolutely massive
all right it was the highest volume we
had since gen whereas amc volume was low
alright so we have definitely a growing
interest in gme and this can be seen by
the move we have today today amc is
moving up two percent gme is moving up
nine percent but the good news guys is
that amc is gonna catch up right as it
always does we we've seen that happening
before
um
gme is not moving without amc amc is not
moving without gme all right so today
jamie is moving up nine percent it's
pretty good news for amc that should
move uh higher
as well or maybe gm is going to pull
back i hope not but you know
something is going to happen that in the
end they they always move together just
a suggestion of maybe something to look
at is like you tell me this percentage
gm is going much faster
what if you look at um
if gme always starts first
and then you do some kind of trade where
you where when gm is so far in advance
and by emcee i have no clue i don't know
if it's gonna work i'm just okay so you
see uh gabriel is proposing an idea
about you know the kind of strategies
that he's using by the way how much
money are you making now so before he
was making 40k
i lost a bit i'm 34.
he lost thousand us dollars but he's
still making 35 as you can see guys
you know just eating breakfast making
35k guys
you know yeah it's moving guys it's
moving so it's it's not a big day but
it's it's a decent day i would say and
hopefully it's positive today it's of
course not positive every day guys
training is always like that there are
some ups and downs you just need to
control your risk you need to
you know take the right decisions at the
right time to keep lucidity guys this is
what is important in trading
um
okay so uh and the proposition
the proposal he just made which is good
i'm gonna have a look at that guys
is wherever whenever so here we have a
good example so let's say let's take
this example right so basically the 87
level of aims of
gme is equivalent to the 14.5 level of
amc right we've seen that before
whenever one is at 14.5 the other one is
usually at 87. so right now
we can check the difference in
percentage between this 14.5 level of
amc
and the 87 level of gme so that we can
have some information
about who is leading okay
and then we can make a spread so i'm not
going to do a spread today okay because
i don't want to sell my shares or maybe
i can sell my shares we we we can see
yes but are you going to be pissed guys
if i if you see selling my shares
because i don't want to you know create
some
bad things you know we are traders guys
but i'm also involved in the amc trade
and the rule is don't sell your shares
i've never sold any share of amc guys
i mean i did one with this we just
stopped us it was very quick guess but i
bought about i bought back quickly i saw
this was annoying for you i don't want
to do it anymore but i'm still gonna
check this trade
so we said 14.5 so we measure from 14.5
to where we are right now so emc took 10
percent
since the 14.5 level okay
and gme roughly the same guys so it's
only a catch up okay from 87
to 97
sorry gme is trending at 98. so jamie
took 13 so jme has two
three percent uh in advance of amc to me
it's not substantial enough given the
volatility involved in these trades uh
to open a position so if i see for
example that gme has 20 percent advance
okay on the way up compared to amc then
a pattern shall trade and for those who
have amc and gme shares think about that
because i will not do it maybe you want
to do it you can reduce your position in
uh in gme okay so sell some of the gm
shares
that is trading 20
premium compared to emc and
buy amc and monitor the spread guys this
is what traders do guys we do some
spreads like that and we just monitor it
and whenever the spreads tightens which
means that amc is going higher more than
jme then you lock in the profits so you
sell the emc shares you just bought and
you re rebuy the gmissions you have and
you can just play around with with those
two but once again yes there is risk in
doing that this is some professional
trailers techniques you need to monitor
that uh well um you need to be aware
that you know stocks can gap up gap down
so again you can get caught uh by doing
that so be careful guys uh once again
let me know if you want to see me doing
things like that if it's interesting for
you
if yes i will monitor the spread and i
will tell you whenever it's better to
buy emc or gme okay uh i'm gonna do a
complete analysis you know because here
i did it quickly i took the 14.5 and 87
level as uh you know a neutral area but
yeah i can check in the past more and
find maybe more
levels like this so that we have more
information
so um yeah just let me know
okay so
so i can see that questions yes i hold
uh i hold shares of amc and gme
and
selji misha's and by amc okay
funny
indeed
so um
i don't know if you guys want to see
that or not just let me know
but i'm happy to do whatever you think
is interesting for you all right
all right guys so it's been
more than three hours that we are live
right now
so we took some positions guys we did
some technical analysis let me have a
look again at my portfolio quickly
okay doing great guys making five
thousand dollars but it's hong kong
dollars once again guys we are
uh
the
the purpose of this portfolio guys is to
reproduce what you guys can make on um
with a little investment i mean 10 20k
so i'm here taking positions uh like
that guys
and of course here today the big
positions at gme guys making good money
on gme
making good money on uso guys i gave you
this trade of course as well
making some good money on x guys making
some you know everything is looking
great today guys
okay no see a defense talk also making
some
money so okay
i think
i think we're gonna stop here guys i'm
very happy that you were here guys and
that we could exchange i hope that you
enjoyed us
that you learn things guys once again
i'm really trying to explain as good as
i can guys everything that we do
uh
once again i'm gonna do that for maybe
one
one month you guys three weeks once
again guys for those who didn't like
this smash that like button guys it's
important for the channel it's helping
me
um
and let us know guys what you want us to
see we can do pretty much whatever you
want but we're gonna take life positions
guys we're gonna prepare maybe some
strategies to explain to you
uh i'll show you do you know the hot
things i'm gonna go through my watch
list again
so thank you very much for uh watching
guys once again we're here with gabriel
guess in panama doing some live trend
and uh we're gonna keep doing that
and thanks again guys so as usual stay
close to show and i see you soon cheers
guys